Frank dwark is back with a new
JavaScript game tutorial featuring
interesting physics and AI mechanics
he's included custom-made royalty-free
assets for you to use and they'll guide
you step by step to create a polished
and responsive browser-based game
[Music]
what makes a perfect game detailed
handcrafted visuals fantasy environments
and a wide variety of animated
characters or is it more about the game
mechanics physics for interactions and
AI to make the creatures feel alive what
is this special ingredient in game
development recipe in this class we will
dive deep into the secrets of JavaScript
web animation and front-end web
development let's try to discover what
makes a great game and how we can build
it from start to finish using just our
own JavaScript code with no Frameworks
and no libraries this class is for
beginners but some basic knowledge of
front-end web development is required to
get them maximum value let's go
I'm giving Olay a ton of free game art
with this class I hope you like it we
will control the blue ball its job is to
protect hatching eggs from waves of
hungry enemies player can position all
the game objects by pushing them around
we can push the ax and hatchlings to
safety or we can push the enemies out of
the way while building this project I
will show you how to use HTML CSS and
plain vanilla JavaScript to implement
many important web animation and game
development techniques we will apply
physics to make game objects interact
with each other we will learn how to
restart our game by pressing a button
how to control FPS of the whole game how
to trigger periodic events we will apply
Mouse controls learn how to manage and
animate 8-directional Sprite sheets we
will trigger and animate particles when
a certain event happens and much more
let's take it step by step to make sure
we really understand the code and by the
end of this class you will have all the
skills you need to build your own games
and animation projects I create an IMG
element with an ID of overlay
The Source will be overlay.png you can
download all project art Assets in the
resources section below there are
individual images and Sprites as I'm
using them in this class as well as a
bonus folder with source files where
each game object comes split into high
resolution pieces you can edit and
animate so if you want you can mix and
match combine them with art I gave you
for other classes where we are using
this mushroom Forest theme and you can
create your own unique game environments
all the art in this class is copyright
free feel free to download them modify
them and reuse them in your own projects
in any way you want I'm already giving
you all art you will need to follow this
course but for those of you who want to
take it further if you have a graphics
editor like Photoshop you can for
example color shift the images to create
even more visual variety character
source files can also be raked and
animated in 2D Sprite tools like dragon
bones or spine check out the source
files and use them however you want it's
my gift to you as a thank you for
spending your time with me so we have a
basic setup in index.html and style CSS
canvas defaults to this small size of
300 X 150 pixels if I set its size with
CSS I would be setting only its element
size and that would stretch my drawings
HTML canvas has actually two sizes
element size and drawing surface size
that can be set independently I want
both sizes to be the same to prevent any
distortions so I will size my canvas
with the JavaScript here I wrap
everything inside load event listener
because we will use a lot of art assets
and I wanted to make sure all my images
are fully loaded and available before
any JavaScript code runs first we need
to point JavaScript towards our canvas
element using get element by ID we save
that reference in this custom variable I
call for example canvas then I take that
variable and from it I call build in get
context method passing it 2D as context
type argument this will initialize a
built-in object that holds all canvas
properties and drawing methods we can
now call them from this CTX variable so
as I said before I want to set canvas
size both element size and drawing
surface size to the same value we can do
it like this canvasa dot width is 1280
pixels and canvas height is 720 pixels
now the full background artwork I
prepared for you is revealed perfect
[Music]
I wanted to ride this game as
object-oriented code base to make it
more modular we will have a class for
player and another class for game to
manage all the game logic the main brain
of this code base we will also need
animation Loop to draw and update our
game over and over to create an illusion
of movement
game class Constructor will expect a
reference to Canvas element as an
argument like this
inside we convert it into a Class
Property
and
we will need with property and the value
will be this dot canvas from line 15 DOT
with like this this will give us 1280
pixels as we set it up on line four
we do the same thing for this dot height
we are taking a reference to Canvas
element and we are setting the width and
height of our game to be the same as the
width and height of canvas we will
finish this setup by connecting this
canvas argument to this canvas variable
a little bit later when we create an
instance of our game class using the new
keyword we will get there soon I'll show
you
before we do that I also need the player
to have access to width and height
properties of our game because the
player needs to know for example when it
moves outside the game area and so on I
will give it access to the entire game
class and all its properties and methods
by passing it a reference to this game
class as an argument like this inside we
convert it to A Class Property keep in
mind that I'm not creating a copy of
game object when I create player objects
in JavaScript are so called reference
data types so this dot game here on line
9 doesn't create a copy it just points
to a space in the memory where our main
game object is stored all the code
inside a class Constructor gets
triggered when we create an instance of
a class using the new keyword we will do
that in a minute I want our code base to
automatically create player when we
create an instance of our main game
object so I can do this inside the class
Constructor I create a property called
this dot player and I set it to new
player like this I can see that player
class Constructor on line 8 expects game
as an argument so I pass it this keyword
since here we are inside that game class
this keyword here refers to the entire
game object here on line 18 we are
creating an instance of player class and
we are saving it as a desktop player
property on the game class structuring
our code like this will automatically
create player when we create game we
create an instance of game object like
this custom variable I call for example
game and I set it equal to new game
on line 14 I can see that the game class
Constructor expects canvas as an
argument so I pass it canvas variable
from Line 2. This variable will get
converted to a class property and the
width and height of the game area will
be extracted from it as we plant let's
check if everything worked by console
login this game variable
nice I can see the correct width and
height properties and we have an
instance of player class in there as
well this is one of the ways how you can
organize and connect your objects in an
object-oriented JavaScript code base
keep in mind that the order in which we
Define the classes matters Javascript
file is read line by line from top to
bottom JavaScript classes are hosted but
they are not initialized until that
particular line is right so player class
needs to be defined before it's used a
very good idea would be to split our
JavaScript into individual modules and
Import and Export our classes between
files as needed for this project I will
write all the code in a single
Javascript file to keep it as beginner
friendly as possible using JavaScript
modules would require us to run this
code through a local server it wouldn't
run The Code by simply opening index
HTML file in a web browser anymore if
you are more experienced it will be very
easy for you to finish the project with
me and then if you want you can split
individual classes into separate modules
yourself this class is for beginners so
let's focus on object oriented
principles and animation techniques
[Music]
a function that sits on an object is
called a method player will need a draw
method to draw and animate it it will
expect context as an argument to specify
which canvas we want to draw on we will
connect this context argument to our CTX
variable from line 3 when we call this
draw method a little bit later I will
show you
I wanted to draw a simple Circle at
first representing our player to draw a
circle on canvas we take context and we
call begin path to tell JavaScript we
want to start drawing a new shape and we
want to close previous shape if there
are any then we call built-in Arc method
which expects at least five arguments it
expects X and Y coordinates of the
center point of the circle its radius
start angle in radians measured from the
positive x-axis and end angle where the
arc ends again in radians measured from
the positive x-axis there is an optional
sixth argument for counterclockwise if
we don't Define it it will default to
false which means that the arc will be
drawn clockwise so start angle is zero
radians and end angle is mastered pi
times two it's a full circle
now we can choose to call fill to fill
the shape with color or stroke just to
outline the shape or we could use both
we will do that soon how do we actually
draw the player on canvas now on the
game class I create a method I call for
example render this method will draw and
update all objects in our game it
expects context as an argument inside I
take this dot player from line 23 and
through this reference we access the
draw method on player class we just
defined from Line 11. This method
contains the code to draw a circle
representing the player I can see it
expects context as an argument so I pass
it along this context we passed to the
render method now I can take this game
variable that holds an instance of the
entire game class and from there I call
render
and I pass it to CTX
from line three
that CTX will be assigned a variable
name context here and it will be passed
along to draw method on player class
we are drawing a black circle
representing the player it's here maybe
you can't see it so let's give it
different X and Y coordinates to move it
instead of hard coding all these values
I want to create properties on the
player class and then use those here
we will need X and Y coordinates for
player position but because in this
class we are learning about position and
hitboxes and character images that can
have very different shapes and sizes I
will have to create property for X and Y
position of player hitbox and I will
need to have a different X and Y
property for player Sprite sheet image
it will make more sense as we build it I
want to be very explicit with my
variable names to make it absolutely
clear which value is the position of the
Collision box and which value is the
position of a Sprite sheet so instead
naming these properties just X and Y I
will name them Collision X and collision
Y X and Y position of the Collision
hitbox of the center point of the
Collision Circle all objects in our game
today will have circular hitboxes
because I wanted to show you how to make
them push and slide along each other I
want the starting position of the player
to be exactly in the middle of the game
area so Collision X will be this dot
game from line 9 and from that property
I will extract with from line 23.
and in the middle so terms of 0.5
Collision y will be the same this Dot
Game dot height times 0.5
now I can use these values as X and Y
arguments but to Canvas Arc method like
this
now we can move the player around by
changing values of collision X and
collision y properties
we will also need a property called
Collision radius which will Define the
size of this circular player hitbox
I use it here inside the arc method as
well
default fill color is always black I can
override it here by setting canvas fill
style property to White like this
instead of filling the shape with color
we could also just stroke it
Again by default line width of stroke is
one pixel and the color is black I set
the line with 2 3 pixels and I set
stroke style to White notice I'm
defining these canvas properties outside
of any class or method I do that on
purpose because this code will only run
once on the initial page load you can't
always do that if you have multiple
objects with different fill Styles and
stroke colors in that case you would
have to Define these properties inside
the draw method and switch between them
over and over the problem with that is
that the draw method will be called 60
times per second and change in kind of a
state like this could get performance
expensive it's a good idea to structure
your code in a way where you change kind
of a state as little as possible and
when I say canvas State I mean anything
from transforms to changing colors of
fill style and stroke style that's why I
put this code here instead of placing it
directly inside the draw method to make
it run as little as possible while still
applying the colors and settings as I
need them
I can also call Phil here so now we are
filling and stroking the same path
defined by Arc method I want the fill to
be white but I want it to be slightly
transparent canvas has a global Alpha
property to set opacity of the shapes we
are drawing the problem is that when I
set Global Alpha to a different value
everything drawn after that will be
semi-transparent I want the transparency
to only apply to the fill color of
player Collision Circle to limit certain
kind of a settings only two specific
draw calls we can wrap that drawing code
between save and restore built-in canvas
methods then if I set Global Alpha to
0.5 it will affect only that specific
draw in action in our case it will only
affect the fill of this circle so save
method creates a snapshot of the current
canvas State including its fill style
line width opacity as well as
Transformations and scaling if we are
doing that then I can do any changes to
that kind of a state I want in this case
I just set opacity to 0.5 this fill call
will be affected by that changed opacity
and then we call Restore restoring all
canvas settings to what they were when
we first called its Associated save
method for that reason this stroke will
not be affected by reduced opacity save
and restore methods allow us to apply
specific drawing settings only to
selected shapes without affecting the
rest of our canvas drawings
[Music]
I want to move the player around using
Mouse we already know that the code
inside the game class Constructor will
be executed at the point where we create
an instance of this class using the new
keyword
we are taking advantage of that by
automatically creating an instance of
player class here we can actually run
any JavaScript code in here
I can even put event listeners here to
make sure they are automatically applied
when I create an instance of game class
I create an event listener for Mouse
down event when Mouse button is clicked
the code inside this callback function
will run I test it by just console login
the word Mouse down
if I save changes because I'm already
instantiating this class online 46 this
event listener is automatically applied
now when I click on canvas control lock
is triggering nice
callback function on event listener also
generates an event object that contains
all kind of information about the event
that just happened to get access to that
object we just need to give it a
variable name you can name it whatever
you want but the convention is usually
event or E let's consolock this event
I click on canvas and I see it here
I inspect it you can see it contains a
lot of information about that Mouse
click for example we see X and Y
coordinates of that click here there are
many other properties that tell us which
Mouse button was pressed and many other
things I want to take the coordinates of
the click and save them as properties on
the main game object and from there we
will be able to access them from our
player object as well
I create a new property on game class
called this.mouse it will be an object
with X property with default value of
this dot width times 0.5 and Y will be
distal height times 0.5 so the middle of
canvas horizontally and vertically
we will also want to monitor when the
mouse button is pressed down initially
it will be set to false
if I consolok e.x and e.y you can see we
are getting X and Y coordinates as we
click around canvas the problem is that
the coordinates are from the top left
edges of the browser window I would like
to measure the click coordinates from
the top left corner of canvas instead so
when we click here in the top left
corner of canvas we get X and Y 0 0. for
that we can use a different property on
this auto-generated event object called
offset X which will give us horizontal
coordinate of the click on the target
node in our case the target node the
target of the click is canvas element
now you can see the values get very
close to zero as I click close to the
edge of canvas
I could also add the event listener just
to the canvas element itself rather than
the entire browser window object
if I click closer to the top left corner
we are getting values close to zero zero
perfect probably it would make sense if
I use this dot canvas property here from
line 31 instead since we are inside a
class and we have the reference to
Canvas available here
so now we are getting coordinates of the
click measured in pixel distance from
the top left corner of canvas
we resize the browser window this is
working well I want to save these click
coordinates inside our custom Mouse
property so that they are available to
other objects in our code base such as
the player
inside the mouse down event listener I
take that this.mouse.x property from
line 36 and I set it equal to e dot
offset X
this.mouse.y will be e dot offset y
I create another console log and I will
log these newly updated Mouse properties
when I click on canvas we get an error
that says cannot set properties on
undefined setting X on line 43. it's
telling me that I can't set X property
on something that is undefined for some
reason this.mouse is undefined when
accessed from inside event listener it
is because when this callback function
on event listener runs it forgot it was
originally defined inside this game
class Constructor it forgets what this
keyword stands for this is expected to
make the event listener remember where
it was first defined where it sits in
the lexical scope of our code base we
can simply use es6 Ro function here
instead one of the special features of
es6 Ro functions is that they
automatically inherit the reference to
this keyword from the parent scope Arrow
functions remember where in the code
base they were originally declared
lexically and they adjust their disk
keyword to point to the correct object
to the parent object now this.mouse.x
and this.mouse.y are correctly updating
to the new values making the current
Mouse coordinates available all over our
code base whenever they might be needed
later
I delete the console logs when Mouse
down event happens I set pressed from
line 38 to true
I copied this event listener
this one will be for Mouse up event
when the mouse button is released
everything here will stay the same and
reset pressed to false
I also create an event listener for
Mouse move event
let's console log it to check
yeah that's working let's make the
player move
[Music]
I create a custom method I call update
inside I set Collision X from line 14 to
the current Mouse exposition
and collision y will be the current
Mouse y position like this to run this
code we actually need to call the update
method
I will call it from inside render down
here
I delete this console log
if we want to see any Movement we need
to be calling render over and over so
let's put it inside the animation Loop
here
I call built-in request animation frame
a method which sits on the browser
window object but we can also call it
directly like this if we want
I pass it animate the name of its parent
function to create an endless animation
Loop now I need to call animate to
actually start the animation
when I move Mouse over canvas we get
Trails I only want to see the current
animation frame so between every loop I
use built-in clear rectangle method to
clear the old paint I want to clear the
entire canvas area from coordinates00 to
canvas with canvas height
now the player sticks to Mouse as we
move it around canvas perfect I want to
create a line between Mouse and the
player to clearly show the direction in
which the player will move inside the
draw method on player class we start a
new shape by calling begin path move 2
method will Define starting X and Y
coordinates of the line in this case I
wanted the line to start from the
coordinates of the player object
line 2 method will set the end in X and
Y coordinates of the line in this case
it would be X and Y coordinates of the
mouse
then we call stroke to actually draw the
line
this works but since the player is
always able to catch up with mouse
cursor so fast we can barely see the
line let's give player speed speed X
horizontal speed initially I set it to
zero
speed y vertical speed also initially
sets to zero
inside update method we will calculate
speed X first I set it to hard-coded one
pixel per animation frame and I increase
player Exposition by horizontal speed
that worked
I also do it for vertical position
there are two ways we can make player
follow the mouse
one way would be to Simply take the
difference between the current Mouse
position and the player position on
horizontal x-axis
and set that difference as horizontal
speed and we also do that for vertical
movement
now the player position is correcting
for the difference by the entire amount
of that distance so it makes the
movement instant what if I make it move
only by the 120th of the difference
between player and mouse position per
animation frame horizontally
and also vertically
I create class properties for DX this
stands between Mouse and player
horizontally and Dy vertical distance
I replace those values here
it's easier to read this way
I don't want the player to follow all
the time as we move Mouse over canvas I
won't only when we click somewhere or
when we hold Mouse button down and move
around
inside Mouse move event listener I say
only update X and Y Mouse position if
Mouse is pressed
now I can click around to make the
player move to that location or I can
drag that point around while holding
Mouse down perfect
the problem with this technique is that
the speed is not constant player moves
very fast at first because 1 20th of the
distance is at first a big chunk when
they are far apart but as they get
closer 1 20th of that distance becomes
smaller and smaller amount of pixels to
be traveled per animation frame you
might want this particular motion for
your project but for the game we are
building today I wanted the player to
move at a constant speed we will have to
use the second technique for that
inside update method I calculated the
distance we already have DX the distance
between Mouse and the player
horizontally we also have DUI the
distance between Mouse and the player
vertically we want to calculate the
distance between these two points we can
do that by calculating hypotenuse the
longest side of this imaginary right
triangle we can use Pythagoras Theorem
formula or in JavaScript we have this
built-in mastered hypotenuse method this
method will calculate the length of the
longest side for us if we pass it to
other sides of the triangle as arguments
keep in mind it expects DUI first and DX
second which might be a bit unexpected
if you never saw this before
horizontal speed is the ratio between DX
horizontal distance between Mouse and
the player and the actual distance
same with speed y it will be the ratio
between the distance on vertical y-axis
and the actual distance between the two
points as a backup when some of these
values are undefined at first we say or
zero like this
we are dividing horizontal and vertical
distance these sides by the actual
distance represented by the longest side
of a right triangle DX and d y is always
a smaller number than the distance
because the distance is hypotenuse the
longest side for that reason the values
we get as speed X and speed y will be
somewhere between 0 and 1. that will
give us the correct direction of
movement at a constant speed there is
much more to be said about this
technique but for now this is all we
need to know I'll get back to this now
the player is moving at a constant speed
towards the mouse I can have a speed
modifier I set it to 5 for example I use
it down here and I multiply speed X
and speed y by that modifier after we
add the speed modifier the player Circle
will actually never stay still anymore
it will be swinging back and forth in
this case by 50 pixels because the speed
modifier pushes it too far in both
directions
I can fix it by saying only move the
player when the distance between Mouse
and the player is more than speed
modifier
else set speed X to Zero and speed y to
0 as well
this works perfect so we covered one
simple and one more advanced technique
to make the player move towards the
mouse now it's time to add solid
randomized non-overlapping obstacles
[Music]
I create a class I call obstacle
Constructor will expect the game as an
argument and inside I convert that
reference to a class property
same as before it will be pointing
towards the main game object and we need
it here because through this reference
we have access to game width and height
Mouse positions and some other
properties we will be adding later
we will have access to all these values
from inside obstacle class through
this.game reference from line 54. as I
explained before all the objects in our
game will have a circular collision
hitbox and a separate rectangular Sprite
sheet for that reason I will be calling
these properties with a very descriptive
names to make sure it's very clear
what's happening when we are moving and
animating everything later Collision X
the center point of collision circle of
each obstacle will be a random value
between 0 and the width of the game that
width is coming from line 62 here and we
are accessing it through this Dot Game
reference we created online 54. we will
also need Collision y vertical center
point of collision area Circle it will
be a random value between 0 and game
height this value
Collision radius will be 60.
we will also need a draw method that
expects context as an argument I want
that Circle that represents hitbox area
of each obstacle to look the same as the
circle representing the player so I take
the drawing code from up here
just for the circle so this code block I
copied and I paste it down here this
code will work here because the same as
with the player we gave our obstacles
properties called Collision X Collision
Y and collision radius
we will also need the same naming on all
these properties between different
object types in case we want to have a
reusable Collision detection function I
will show you how to use that one later
it's simple anyway here we have a code
to draw a circle with a radius of 60
pixels with 50 opacity wide fill and
white fully visible full opacity stroke
this obstacle class here is a blueprint
we will use it to create individual
obstacle objects the actual logic to
create and manage these objects will be
down here inside the main game class
which is the main brain of our code base
I create a property called this dot
obstacles it will be an array that holds
all currently active obstacle objects it
will start as an empty array at first
the number of obstacles will be for
example 5.
I create a custom method on our game
class I call for example init initialize
its job for now will be to create five
randomized obstacle objects and put them
inside obstacles array we just defined
inside I create a for Loop it will run
five times because we set number of
obstacles to 5 up on line 76.
each time it runs it will take this dot
obstacles array from line 77 and on it
it will call built-in array push method
push method adds one or more elements to
the end of an array and it Returns the
new length of the array I will pass it
new obstacle like this the new keyword
will look for a class with the name
obstacle and it will trigger its class
Constructor
up online 53 I can see that obstacle
class Constructor expects the game as an
argument
down here init method sits inside that
game class so I pass it this keyword
which here represents the entire game
object with all its properties and
Associated methods making all of these
available from inside obstacle class
now icons look a game and I can see
obstacles array is completely empty to
fill it all I have to do is call init
method we just wrote like this now I can
see the array contains five obstacle
objects I double check to make sure all
properties have values if you see
undefined in any of these it means there
is a problem in your code base all is
good here same as I'm drawing and
updating the player from inside game
render method here I would like to draw
all five obstacle objects on canvas
I take obstacles array from -77 we
already know that it contains five
objects and that each of these objects
was created using our custom obstacle
class from ion 52 so they all have
access to this draw method we defined on
line 59 so here inside render I take
that obstacles array and I call built-in
array for each method the for each
method executes a provided function once
for each array element first we need to
Define a variable name which will be
used within this for each method to
refer to individual objects in that
array I will call each object obstacle
so for each obstacle object in obstacles
array I call their Associated draw
method from line 59. on line 59 I can
see that it expects a reference to
context as an argument to specify which
canvas element we want to draw on
it's along this context that was passed
to the parent render method
nice we are drawing one player and one
two three four five randomly positioned
obstacles
I go
up here and I make the obstacles a bit
larger every time I refresh browse the
window they get positioned randomly
somewhere within the canvas area because
that's how we Define their position on
lines 55 and 56. what if I want to make
sure that the obstacles never overlap
like this and maybe to take it even
further since these will be solid
obstacles that player can't move through
and has to walk around them I would also
like there to be a minimum spacing
between them and also between the edges
of the game area just to make sure all
the creatures that will soon be crawling
here don't get stuck and can eventually
find their way automatically around each
obstacle it's actually easier to
implement all of that than you might
think but we have to take it step by
step and explain a couple of Tricks we
can use here to achieve that
[Music]
inside init method we are simply adding
five randomly positioned obstacles right
now
I have to delete this
we will need to structure this code a
bit differently here so first I want to
make sure the obstacles don't touch that
they don't overlap like this we could
also adjust the number of obstacles to
be the maximum number of circles
possible that can fit into a certain
area without any two of them overlapping
sometimes we call this circle back in so
let's write a very simple Circle backing
algorithm here I will use the basic
technique where you just try to place
circles at random positions many times
and only those that don't collide with
already existing circles will actually
be turned into obstacle objects and
drawn this is also called a Brute Force
algorithm it's not very smart it just
tries over and over many many times I
will create a lead variable called
attempts it will be my safety measure we
will count how many times we tried to
draw a circle and we will give up after
a certain number of attempts the
Assumption being that there must have
already been enough opportunity entities
to place the obstacles
I will use a while loop you have to be
careful with this one if you create an
infinite while loop you will slow down
your browser and you will need to
restart it very old computers might even
freeze if you use while a loop wrong new
browsers can usually deal with it my
goal here is to randomly Place circles
over and over and before we actually
turn that circle into obstacle object we
check if it overlaps with existing
circles only if it doesn't overlap we
add it into the obstacles array I want
this while loop to run as long as
optical's array length is less than
number of obstacles less than five
we defined that array here and number of
obstacles was defined here as a backup I
also set a secondary condition only
continue running this while loop as long
as attempts is less than 500. this is
important because if I set radius of an
obstacle to be a very large number or I
set number of obstacles to be so large
that they can't physically fit into the
available area we would get an endless
while loop but with this secondary
condition JavaScript will just try 500
times and if by that time they couldn't
find placement for all the obstacles it
will give up
think 500 attempts is more than enough
every time the loop runs we have to
increase attempts by one for our safety
backup plan to work every time this
while loop runs we create a temporary
object I call for example test obstacle
it will be equal to the new obstacle and
I pass it again this keyword as an
argument as we did before let's
consolock this test obstacle
nice we have 500 test obstacles in
console now you can see they have
Collision X Collision Y and collision
radius properties as they should my goal
now is to take this temporary test
obstacle object and compare it against
every other obstacle in obstacles array
of course at first this array is empty
so the first obstacle should always be
placed without issues the second test
obstacle will compare itself with the
first one that's already in the array
and so on so for each obstacle in
obstacles array I will run a circle
Collision detection formula Circle
Collision detection in JavaScript is
quite simple we basically need to
calculate the distance between the two
Center points of those two circles then
we compare the distance between two
Center points with the sum of the radii
if the distance is less than radius of
circle 1 Plus radius of circle 2 they
overlap if it's exactly the same the
circles are touching if the distance is
more then the sum of radii there is no
Collision we already did this when
measuring the distance between player
and mouse this time the two points we
want to measure the distance in between
is the center point of obstacle Circle
one and center point of obstacle Circle
2. so again we are creating this
imaginary right triangle where DX is the
difference between two points
horizontally Dy is the difference
between the two points vertically and
the actual distance is the hypotenuse of
that triangle so here we use Pythagoras
Theorem formula or a built-in method
hypotenuse method passing it to DUI
first and DX second so now we know what
is the distance between the two Center
points sum of radii is a radius of
circle one in this case radius of test
obstacle
and the second one is the radius of
whatever obstacle object inside
obstacles array we are currently cycling
over
as we said if the distance is less than
sum of radii
how will I do this outside the for each
method I create a flag a lead variable I
call overlap and initially I set it to
false if the distance is less than sum
of radii we set overlap to true because
Collision was detected
outside the for each method if overlap
is still false after we created test
obstacle and after we compared it using
Collision detection formula with every
other existing obstacle in the array if
it doesn't collide with any of them and
overlap a variable is still false after
all these checks only then we take
obstacles array and we will push this
test obstacle that passed our checks
into the array now when I refresh the
game five obstacles will be randomly
positioned and they will not be
overlapping because those that do
overlap are discarded and only
non-overlapping circles are used because
I have my safety measure here on line
108 and we always stop this while loop
when we reach 500 attempts I can
actually go up here and I can set the
number of obstacles to a large number
that I know will never fit our code will
just place as many obstacles as possible
and then it will stop trying we know
this is working because if I keep
refreshing my project over and over we
never see overlap in circles I mean no
obstacles overlap with each other player
can overlap at this point with obstacles
we don't care about that right now I set
the number of obstacles to 10.
[Music]
now let me show you how we will be
attaching images to the circular
collision hitboxes and how to position
the image in relation to the hitbox so
that it makes Visual sense and creates
an illusion that this is not flat canvas
but a three-dimensional environment
where the player can actually walk
around these obstacles you can download
all project art Assets in the resources
section Below in index.html I create
another image element with an ID of
obstacles and Source will be
obstacles.png that image is a Sprite
sheet we will randomly cut out one of
these frames for each obstacle object I
don't really want to draw the actual
image element so I hide it with CSS
inside obstacle class Constructor I
create a new property I call this dot
image I point it towards that obstacle
Sprite sheet using get element by ID
like this
let's set the number of obstacles to one
for now
inside the draw method on obstacle class
I call built-in canvas draw image method
this method needs at least three
arguments the image we want to draw so
this dot image from line 58
and X and Y coordinates where to draw it
I will draw it at this dot Collision X
and this dot Collision Y at first doing
this will simply draw the entire image
Sprite sheet and the top left corner of
this Sprite sheet will be starting from
the center point of obstacle Circle
because this is how by default images
and circles are drawn on HTML canvas
if I refresh the project our new
obstacle is positioned randomly
somewhere on canvas I created this
Sprite sheet for you so I know that
individual frames are 250 pixels wide I
save that value as Sprite width variable
Sprite height will also be 250 pixels if
you are using a different spreadsheet
you can get the width by dividing the
width of the entire Sprite sheet by the
number of columns and the height is
height of the Sprite sheet divided by
the number of rows
in case we want to add scaling later I
will also create independent width and
height properties for now they will be
equal to Sprite width and Sprite height
because I sized the Sprite frames to the
exactly same size as I want them to be
drawn in the game
draw image can also accept optional
fourth and fifth arguments defined in
the width and height the entire image
will be squeezed or stretched to the
area we defined by these values
it will look like this
what I actually want to do is to crop
out one of these 12 obstacles and draw
only that one at the size of 250 times
250 pixels for that I need to use the
longest version of draw image method
that expects 9 arguments those nine
arguments are the image we want to draw
Source X Source y Source width and
Source height of the area we want to
crop out from the source image and
destination X destination y destination
with and destination height to Define
where on destination canvas I want to
place that cropped out piece of image
onto so if I pass it 0 as a source X and
0 as Source height and Sprite with
Sprite height like this as Source width
and Source height I need to spell width
correctly so now we are drawing the top
left frame in our Sprite sheet as I said
before I will set separate X and Y
position for the Sprite sheet there are
multiple different ways to do this I can
just simply position the image directly
on top of collision X which is the
center point of collision Circle minus
the width of the image times 0.5 this
will Center the image horizontally
exactly over the Collision Circle
to actually apply this I need to use
Sprite X as destination X property
passed to draw image method here be
careful when passing arguments to draw
image method the order in which you pass
these arguments is very important okay
if I refresh the page I can see it's
been correctly centered horizontally I
do the same thing for sprite y
and I use it as destination y property
passed to draw image method
now the spreadsheet is directly on top
of the Collision Circle I set Collision
radius to a smaller value I want this
small Collision area to be positioned at
the base of the plant where the stone is
because that will be the solid area
that's touching the ground that our game
characters will have to walk around
since our Sprites are set size of 250
times 250 pixels I can actually use a
hard-coded value here plus 40 we'll move
it up
minus 40.
minus 50.
minus 60
minus 70. yes this seems all right I
said that the number of obstacles to 10.
[Music]
what if I want to make sure that not
obstacles so don't overlap but also that
there is a additional minimum 100 pixel
space in between so that they are more
evenly spaced out around the available
game area as well as allowing enough
space in between the obstacles so the
game characters can easily walk around
them I create a helper variable I call
for example distance buffer and I set it
to 100 pixels like this
then I include the distance buffer here
in sum of radii to apply this buffer in
between obstacles when we are placing
them
nice to make sure this is working I
increase distance buffer to 150 pixels
that should make it even more apparent
yeah so this is how we can easily
control obstacle spacing
I also want to make sure that obstacle
Sprite images are entirely drawn within
the game area and not partially hidden
behind the edges I could have done this
inside obstacle class Constructor when
defining these values initially or I can
also just do it here since we are not
drawing that many obstacles and their
positions are calculated only once on
the first page load anyway I make sure
the left edge of obstacle Sprite sheet
is more than zero so it's not hidden
behind the left edge of canvas at the
same time I make sure that the right
Edge is not hidden so Sprite X must be
less than the width of the game area
minus the width of the obstacle
nice when I refresh the page I can see
horizontally obstacles are always fully
visible for vertical position I want to
check the image but at the center point
of collision a circle more than zero
vertically will not be enough I want to
Define an area that is reserved for this
background artwork I don't want to Grant
obstacles to appear over this area I
create a property called top margin
I guess a desktop area is around 260
pixels of height
let's check here
yes 260 looks alright because I want to
make sure the base of the obstacles
doesn't overlap with this top area but I
don't mind if the top of the obstacle
Sprite sheets overlaps like this because
this looks like the obstacle plant is
standing in front of the background
Forest View so this is fine
I will also check if the center point of
obstacle Collision area circle is less
than the height of the game area
I want some margins I can for example
create a helper variable that's equal to
Collision radius of the test obstacle
times two
I replaced this hard-coded value with
this.top margin property we defined plus
I want to give it some additional top
margin so that characters and special
enemies can squeeze in between obstacles
and game boundaries when walking across
the game field horizontally from right
to left
I will also account for the margin from
the bottom of the game area to create
some space there
we wrote code that automatically places
obstacles in our game World these
obstacles never overlap and their
correlation areas are placed to allow
enough space in between them this will
make the next steps much easier because
we need enemies and friendly NPCs to be
able to automatically walk around them
using very simple artificial
intelligence
we have different images for obstacles
but right now we are drawing only the
first top left frame at coordinate 0 0.
we can crop out different areas from the
obstacles Sprite sheet horizontal crop
area will start from the position we
pass as Source X argument to draw image
method here zero times Sprite width is
this Frame one times Sprite width will
be this Frame two is this one three is
this one back to zero to select from
which row we are cropping we use Source
y argument here again we multiply row
number by the actual height of
individual Sprite frames so zero times
Sprite height is this one times Sprite
height is this now we are on Row 2 and
there is no Row 3 because we start from
row zero images are drawn and cropped
from the top so instead of hard coding
these values that are currently set to 0
0 let's turn them into class properties
for cloud Authority and easy control
this.frame X will determine which column
we are on in our obstacle Sprite sheet
if I do a random number between 0 and 4
this will not work there is no column
1.74 for example we need integers
numbers without decimal points so I wrap
it in my third floor to round the random
value generated by Mazda random to the
closest lower integer this code will
give me either 0 or 1 or 2 or 3. so one
of our Sprite columns
when we multiply these integers by the
width of a single Sprite frame and we
pass that value as a source X argument
to draw image method we are defining
horizontal cropping coordinate
that worked perfect I will do the same
for frame Y which will determine Sprite
row we have only three rows this line of
code will give me integers either 0 or 1
or 2 corresponding to the number of rows
we have available in our obstacle Sprite
sheet now we can replace this hard-coded
0 with this dot frame y so Source y
argument passed the draw image method
will be this dot frame y times this dot
Sprite height I will do that in a second
random values in frame X and frame y
combined will give us random image out
of these 12 available obstacles each
obstacle object will have random frame
from this Sprite sheet assigned to it I
will finish this a bit later
[Music]
on the main game object I create a
method I call check Collision I want
this to be a reusable utility method
that takes object a and object B and it
will compare them and check if they are
collided or not we will be able to use
this all over the code base wherever
Collision detection between two circles
is needed
the way I'm building my game all
characters and objects will have a
circular Collision area which will be a
solid base that nothing can walk through
and everything will react and walk
around everything using this we can also
push things around I will show you to
check collision between two circles we
have Circle A and A Circle B here we
need to check DX first the distance
between the center point of Circle A and
the center point of Circle B on
horizontal x-axis this reusable method
will work only if all objects involved
have properties with same name and
conventions so we will make sure we name
X and Y positions on each object as
Collision X and collision y
I'm using this overly descriptive
property names so that it's very clear
when X and Y coordinates relate to
Collision area Circle and when they
relate to image Sprite sheet positions
this is a tutorial so I want things to
be very clear and easy to understand
[Music]
we will also need a DUI the difference
between the center point of Circle A and
the center point of Circle B on the
vertical y-axis
then we want to know the distance
between these two Center points so
hypotenuse the longest side of this
imaginary right triangle right angle 90
degrees is here and this is the distance
Pythagoras Theorem formula or
alternatively built-in method hypotenuse
method and we pass it Dy first and the X
as the second argument
to determine whether or not there is a
collision We compare distance between
these two Center points with radius of
Circle A Plus radius of Circle B I will
save this value as a custom variable I
call for example sum of radii
so if this tense is less then sum of
radii we know the circles Collide if the
distance is the same as the sum of radii
circles are touching if the distance is
more than the sum of radii we know there
is no Collision this function will
simply return true if there is collision
and false if there is no Collision
let's use our custom check Collision
function
up here inside update method on player
class we check for collision between
player and obstacles we have a one
player object and multiple obstacle
objects so to compare all we will call
for each on obstacles array which holds
all currently active obstacle objects I
will call each object in the array with
a helper variable name obstacle and I
will console log check Collision method
we just defined we know it expects
circular object a and circle object b as
arguments to compare the distance of
their Center points to the sum of their
radii so I pass it this which means this
player object as Circle 1 and obstacle
we are currently cycling over with this
for each method as Circle B
keep in mind that this reusable check
Collision method can only compare
objects that have Collision X Collision
Y and collision radius properties
defined in their class Constructor
so I will make sure I keep the same name
and conventions for all objects in the
game we are building today as the player
moves we are getting false and true in
the console seems like this is working
let's actually only console log the word
Collision when collision between player
and obstacle is happening now it's even
easier to see that our code is working
perfect
inside render method I will draw
obstacles first so behind and player
after it so it will be drawn on top what
if I want to also resolve our collisions
what I mean is if player collides with
an obstacle I don't want it to be able
to walk through it like this I want the
player Circle to be pushed one pixel
back away from the obstacle Circle in
the direction that points directly away
from the center point of the obstacle
this simple thing will make the obstacle
solid and the player will actually slide
around the obstacles and it will create
nice physics let me show you
I'm already calculating everything I
need for that inside our custom check
Collision method but this function
currently returns only true or false I
need this reusable method to return more
values so that we can use them inside
player class to calculate Collision
resolution Vector functions and methods
in JavaScript can return one value like
this but they can also return an array
that contains multiple values I want to
return true or false Collision status as
the first element in the array element
with an index of zero we also want to
return the distance we are calculating
on line 127
we will also need some over ADI from
line 128 and we will need DX and Dy from
lines 125 and 126. so now our custom
check Collision method not only checks
if Collision is happening or not it also
gives us other values from calculations
that happened along the way it's
important that we remember the order in
which we are returning these values
element with an index of 0 is Collision
status true or false element with an
index of 1 is the distance sum of radii
is index 2 DX is index 3 and d y is
index 4. I will just copy that array
that gets returned here and I comment it
out just so I can see it as a helper
reference
now I want to take each of these values
and save them as separate variables so
that we can use them to calculate
Collision resolution here and push to
player in the correct direction away
from the obstacle it's currently
colliding with I will use something
called restructuring assignment let's
just write it and I will explain it when
we see the whole thing
I say let variable is this array
and it is equal to check collision
between this player object and the
obstacle that for each method is
currently cycling over
I have to replace this first expression
with a variable name I want to call it I
want to call it Collision
it will be that true or false value
depending on the distance between Circle
Center points so if this is true there
is Collision if this is false there is
no Collision
the structuring assignment syntax is a
JavaScript expression that makes it
possible to unpack values from arrays or
properties from objects into distinct
variables I'm basically saying here
create five variables for me the first
variable called Collision is the array
returned when we call check Collision
method between displayer and obstacle
index 0 distance variable is that array
index 1 and so on the structuring
assignment does this automatically
behind the scenes it creates these five
variables and pairs them with the values
that sit at these indexes in the array
returned by check Collision method
this might be a bit strange if you never
saw it before JavaScript destructuring
is a good thing to get familiar with
modern Frameworks use it a lot I'm
basically just taking the array returned
by check Collision method and I'm
assigning each value to its separate
variable name so that I can use them
here
so here we are inside update method on
player class we are cycling through
obstacles array comparing player with
each obstacle object if there is
collision between player and obstacle if
Collision variable is true we consolock
AAA
this works I want to create a vector
kind of a small line between 0 and 1
pixels in length that line will point in
the direction in which we want the
player to be pushed to resolve the
circle Collision to make sure that
colliding player and obstacle repel each
other causing the player to slide along
the radius of the obstacle rather than
going directly through it horizontal
Vector will be the ratio between DX
distance between player and obstacle
center point on the horizontal x-axis
and the actual distance between these
two points we calculated before using
check Collision method because DX will
always be less than distance because
distance is hypotenuse it's always the
longest side of the imaginary right
triangle unit X will always be a value
between a 0 and 1 because we are
dividing smaller value by a large value
unit y will be the ratio between d y the
distance between Center points on the
vertical y-axis and they are actual
distance between the two Center points
again it will be a value somewhere
between 0 and 1. this could also be
negative values depending on how our
objects sit in relation to each other on
horizontal and vertical axes so actually
unit X and unit y will be a value
between -1 and plus 1.
if I consulate unit X and unit y we can
see these values the combination of
these two values being added to players
horizontal and vertical position for
each animation frame will make it move
in a certain direction and certain speed
away from the center point of the
obstacle
I do that by taking player Collision
Exposition the center point of players
Collision Circle
to push it outside the radius of the
obstacle it is colliding with I move it
horizontally to the position of center
point of obstacle circle plus the sum of
radii of player Circle and the obstacle
circle plus one additional pixel outside
times that unit X ratio to give it the
right direction away from the obstacle's
center point
we do the same thing vertically center
point of player Collision Circle will be
moved to the position of collision
center of obstacle circle plus sum of
radii of obstacle and player circle plus
1 pixel times unit y to give it the
right direction of the push I am trying
to explain this in a very beginner
friendly way but don't worry if it's
still a bit unclear this is an important
technique and every time you use it you
will feel more and more familiar with
this code eventually it will click for
you how it works all you have to
understand here is that this code is
pushing the player one pixel outside the
Collision radius of the obstacle in the
direction away from the center point
this is how you create very simple but
very effective physics simulation in
your game try to move the player around
this feels very good doesn't it suddenly
our obstacle circles turned into solid
impossible objects well done if you
followed all the way here this is the
main trick we are using today for our
physics game
I adjust the speed modifier to a smaller
value we learned how to make the player
move towards a mouse or towards a
specified point in a 2d space and how to
make it navigate its way automatically
around solid obstacles this is a
powerful technique and you can do with
it more than you can imagine we will
explore some of that today hope you're
having fun
[Music]
I prepared a special 8-directional
player Sprite shoot for this class you
can download it in the resource section
below
I will include some alternative colors
probably mine is blue too much to
mushrooms in my game art
I will hide it with CSS here
inside player class Constructor I create
a reference to that image using get
element by ID and I save it as
this.image property
inside our custom draw method I take
context and I call built-in canvas draw
image method that we already used before
we already said that the draw image
method needs at least three arguments
the image we want to draw and X and Y
where to draw it this will just draw the
entire Sprite sheet
we can pass it width and height to
squeeze the entire Sprite sheet into
that specified area
we actually don't have these properties
defined Sprite with the width of a
single frame will be 255 pixels Sprite
height is 255 as well then we create
separate width and height properties to
allow the potential if we want to
introduce it later now we are squeezing
the entire Sprite sheet into the area of
one Sprite frame you probably already
know that we will need the longest
version of draw image method where we
add Source X Source y Source width and
Source height these values will first
crop out a portion of the image in our
case a single Sprite frame after that we
draw that frame at the position defined
by the last four arguments
to draw the top left frame at coordinate
0 0 is simple we just did it with
obstacle Sprite sheet
Source X Source y 0 0 to define the
beginning of cropping rectangle and
Sprite width and Sprite height as Source
width and Source height arguments to
Define its size now we see only one
frame
I will calculate position of sprite
sheet image in relation to Collision X
and collision Y coordinates of player
hitbox in these two separate properties
just for clarity so keep in mind these
properties Define the center point of
player Collision Circle these two
properties will Define the top left
corner of sprite sheet frame image we
are currently drawing to represent the
player
on canvas Circle coordinates are from
the center point rectangle and image
coordinates are from its top left corner
and image and rectangle goes towards
right bottom depending on its width and
height from there
we have to consider this when writing
the following code
Sprite X will be positioned in relation
to Collision area it will be Collision X
the center point of collision Circle
minus half of the width of player frame
like this
I need to use Sprite X inside the draw
image method as destination X argument
here
and for this to work we need to
recalculate this value every time
Collision X updates so I need to put
this inside the update method here and I
also do it for sprite Y which will be
Collision y minus the half of player
height
I can delete it here
and I use Sprite y property here as a
destination y argument past the draw
image method
now it's positioned on top I actually
want this Collision Circle to match the
little shadow on the ground below the
player as closely as possible because
that's the contact point we will use
when interacting with other objects in
our game since the player is fixed pixel
size I can offset it by a hard-coded
value if we were scaling our characters
in this game I would use a relative
value here minus 100 moved the player
image up
so this is all right for now
[Music]
same as we did with obstacles Sprite
sheet I want to navigate within our
Sprite sheet by swapping from frame to
frame horizontal navigation is handled
by multiplying Sprite width by an
integer representing the column in the
Sprite sheet passed as Source X argument
here when we cycle through this we will
animate individual directions
individual animation Loops to swap
between directions in the spreadsheet
the way our specific Sprite sheet is
organized today we have to multiply
Sprite height by an integer representing
Sprite row you can see row 0 is player
facing upwards away from us Row 1 is top
right two is the player facing right
three is bottom right 4 is facing down
towards the camera Row 5 in our Sprite
sheet is the player facing bottom left 6
is facing in left I think you get the
idea I put these integers into class
properties
frame X for horizontal Sprite navigation
frame y for vertical I replace these
hard-coded values with my new variables
and now I can change what frame we are
currently cropping out from the player
Sprite sheet by giving different values
to frame X and frame y
I want to change frame y the row we are
currently animating from the Sprite
sheet which will determine where the
player is facing I want that to depend
on the current angle between Mouse and
the player on the position where they
are currently in relation to each other
for this we have a built-in method
called mass.atan2
[Music]
returns an angle in radians between the
positive x-axis and a line projected
from 0 0 towards a specific point we
will use it to calculate the angle
between the player and mouse cursor and
based on that angle we will select which
Row in the Sprite sheet we want to
animate so that the player is always
facing in the direction it is moving
towards the mouse cursor we will need DX
and d y so I move them up here
so these values calculated the distance
between the player and mouse cursor
horizontally and vertically keep in mind
that it makes a difference if you use
Mouse first or the player first in this
calculation I already wrote this code
here before without thinking we would
use it for this so we might have to
adjust to it a bit I will show you
exactly what I mean Master datan 2
expects DUI first and DX as the second
argument
I will consult angle we are calculating
and I can see it is changing and the
values are from a minus 3.14 minus Pi 2
plus 3.14 plus pi this checks out
because we know that full circle is 2 pi
approximately 6.28 radians which
converts to 360 Degrees I will repeat
that method A10 2 returns an angle in
radians between the positive x-axis and
a line projected from 0 0 towards a
specific point because I'm using Mouse
first and the player position second
when calculating DX and d y I'm getting
values from a math.a time to where the
current Mouse position represents point
zero zero and player position is the
point we are projecting a line towards
for the purposes of a nice visual it
would work much better if player was the
static 0 0 center point but I will leave
with others and from the values I'm
getting in the console I will create
this graph with breakpoints in radians
it was actually easy to make because I
just needed one value as an anchor and I
knew the whole area is from -3.14 to
plus 3.14 and we have eight player
directions so each slice was 6.28
divided by 8. anyway you don't
necessarily have to understand all of
this right now when we have the full
code you can play with the values which
will hopefully bring more clarity it
took me a while of using math but atan 2
before I fully understood so if this is
your first time seeing it don't put too
much pressure on yourself
if I pause the screen this is the point
zero zero this is the line projected
towards another point and master data
and 2 gives us an angle in radians
between this positive x-axis and this
line so by using this console log to get
an anchor point so that I can see which
angle values we are getting I
constructed this helper visual which I
will now use to correctly swap player
rows in our Sprite sheet to make the
player always face the mouse
if angle is less than -1.17 set frame y
to zero
I will copy this a few times
minus 0.39 is frame y 1 plus 0.39 is
frame Y2
1.17 radians is frame Y3
1.96 is frame y4 let's see hmm
so far this is working great I think we
got it I can delete the console log
2.74 is frame 5. this area is a bit
weird as the circle ends and starts I
have to say if angle is less than minus
2.74 or if angle is more than plus 274
I want to use frame Y6
if angle is less than minus 1.96 frame Y
is 7. pay attention to brackets here
minus and plus values and less than
operators if you are getting any
unexpected Behavior make sure all of
this code is the same as mine it's easy
to make a small mistake here and break
your code accidentally
for this to work for all directions I
have to adjust it a bit I can for
example take these lines and put them
here because with else if statement it
matters which one is checked first
sometimes
I reduce the player speed modifier to 3
so we can clearly see how it turns while
destined
now we can turn the player in all eight
directions perfect we will learn more
about sprite animation later in the
class for now I'm happy with this
[Music]
physics game where we are placing
Collision areas at the base of each
object we want to be able to quickly
swap between the view where these
Collision areas are visible and
invisible it will help us to tweak the
physics and gameplay elements as we are
developing them while giving us an easy
way to check how the changes we just
made will be visible for the player who
will not see these hitboxes I want to
create a debug mode by pressing letter D
on the keyboard we will toggle all
helper Collision elements on and off on
the main game class I create a property
called this dot debug and initially I
set it to
true
down here where we placed our event
listeners I create another one we will
listen for key down event
let's just console event object when I
select canvas by clicking on it and then
I press any keyboard key we get this
Auto generated keyboard event object
inside we have a property called key you
can see I pressed letter R so the key
that was pressed sits inside e.key
property
I say if e dot key is a d set debug
property from line 123 to its opposite
value so if it's currently true set it
to false if it's false set it to true
this way pressing the same key letter D
will toggle debug mode on and off
I tested by console login this dot debug
I press D over and over and in console I
see it switches between true and false
perfect I remove the console log
up here inside the draw method on
obstacle class I say if this dot
game.deback is true only then draw the
Collision area Circle
now I can press letter D to show and
hide them that works well
I want to do the same for the player if
this dot game.deback is true only then
draw the Collision Circle and also the
line between the player and the mouse in
this case positioning and size of the
hitboxes is not perfect yet but we do
have all the logic in place now great
job I can make a collision radius of
each obstacle smaller to better match
the part where it touches the ground
we have different obstacle types here
the mushroom and this big carnivorous
plant should probably have different
Collision circles which can easily be
done but for now I'm happy with this you
can see that the Collision formula we
wrote before is all we need to give the
player very simple path finding ability
it will just walk around obstacles
automatically and since we placed
obstacles in a way that there are always
spaces in between it's unlikely that the
player will get stuck
I can also see I'm only getting the
first four obstacle images which reminds
me to go here to line 108 and include
randomized frame y value as Source y
argument in obstacle draw image method
now I'm randomly getting one of all 12
obstacle images you can play with this
end position and size your hitboxes
differently if you want I'm happy with
what we did so far
[Music]
I wanted to make sure the player can't
walk so high that it's above this
background artwork area let's create
some horizontal boundaries first
point of player Collision circle is less
than x coordinate 0 plus Collision
radius set it to zero plus Collision
radius so when the left edge of the
circle is touching the left edge of
canvas area don't allow it to go any
further left
I want to do the same thing for the
right Edge
of course we can delete this zero plus
here and here
if the center point of player Collision
circle is more than the width of the
game minus the radius of player
Collision Circle
make sure it can't go any further right
nice
vertical boundaries
if Collision Y is less than vertical
coordinate zero plus top margin we
defined to be 260 pixels from the top
plus Collision radius
make sure that the player can't go any
more up
that works nice
this is what I wanted
again we can delete 0 plus here and here
bottom boundary
that's simple if Collision Y is more
than the height of the game minus
Collision radius
make sure it stops there like this
that works if I make player Collision
radius smaller than obstacle radius
because of the margin we defined while
positioning obstacles there will always
be a place for a player to squeeze
between obstacles and the edges of game
area
there is not so
down here I increase that margin
they should do it you can compare your
code with in progress source code I will
include to download in a project section
Below in multiple points during this
class as we progress with our project
[Music]
I can see the bottom of the Sprite sheet
is being cut off on the lower rows it's
because the height of a single frame is
actually 256 pixels
now it's fixed
in Visual Studio code editor I select
the view word wrap to make the code
break to another line if it cannot fade
if it's too long I want to set FPS for
the entire game because with my previous
project a lot of you mentioned that
games run too fast on your game in high
refresh rate screens request animation
frame a method we are using here will
automatically adjust itself to screen
refresh rate so for normal screens that
would be around 60 frames per second but
on some of the new gaming screens that
people use that speed would be double or
maybe not exactly double but much faster
we will calculate Delta time the amount
of milliseconds that passed between each
call of request animation frame and we
will only allow the game to serve the
next animation frame when a specific
number of milliseconds has passed
we can calculate the Delta time down
here inside our custom animate function
first I Define last time outside the
function like this initially I set it to
zero this variable will always hold a
reference or
the amp from the previous animation Loop
so that we can compare it with the
current timestamp and the difference
between them will be Delta time request
animation frame has two special features
as we said it will automatically try to
adjust itself to the screen refresh rate
in most cases 60 frames per second
it will also automatically generate a
timestamp for us that we can use and it
will pass that timestamp as an argument
to the function it calls in our case
animate imagine it's passing the
timestamp here like this automatically
it's Auto generated all we have to do to
use it is to assign it a variable name
here I will call it timestamp spelled
like this be mindful of Laurel and
uppercase letters when defining your
variable names in JavaScript it matters
let's just console log this
auto-generated timestamp variable that
request animation frame is giving us
just to see what format it is in you can
see it gives us milliseconds since the
first animate was called one second is a
thousand milliseconds so here I can
literally see that the game started 9 10
11 12 13 seconds ago I delete this
console log we know we have access to
the current timestamp so let's use it to
calculate Delta time it will be the
difference between the timestamp from
this animation Loop and the timestamp
from the previous animation Loop Delta
time is the number of milliseconds it
took our computer to serve the next
animation frame once we used last time
to calculate Delta time we assign it to
the current timestamp this way the
current timestamp can be used in the
next animation loop as the old timestamp
for the very first animation Loop last
time will be zero but after that it will
always hold the value of the tab step
from the previous animation frame so
that we can compare it with the value of
timestamp from this currently running
animation frame and that difference
between them is Delta time
so let's consolow Delta time to see if
it worked my Delta time is around 16.6
milliseconds thousand milliseconds
divided by 60 is 16.6 so this checks out
I wonder how many of you got the same
Delta time and how many of you got a
different number if you have a high
refresh screen your Delta time will be a
much smaller number if you have an old
computer that is struggling to animate
our game your Delta time might be much
higher if you have a second to write
your Delta time in the comments so we
know if most people get the same or very
different values than me it will help me
to better optimize my future courses
if I scroll up in the console to the
very first timestamp you can see that
the first two values of Delta time are
none not a number it is because the very
first timestamp is undefined because
only on the second Loop this timestamp
value gets Auto generated by request
animation frame the first Loop is not
triggered by request animation frame
it's triggered by this line so in the
beginning when we say that Delta time is
undefined minus 0 here we get none not a
number it automatically fixes itself as
the loop runs but these two initial not
a number of values could break your code
that depends on Delta time unless you
account for it with some kind of or
statement for example the easiest way to
fix this is to pass 0 here as the
timestamp for the first animation loop
from the second Loop the value will
become the auto generated downstamp
because after that animate will be
called by request animation frame as you
can see we get numbers here and there
are no non-values anymore perfect
I delete this console log
so let's use Delta time to set frame
rate of our game we will need some
helper variables FPS frames per second
will be for example 20. timer will count
over and over from zero towards a
specific value when it reaches that
value it will trigger the next animation
frame and it will reset back to zero
interval will be that breakpoint value
that when reached will reset timer
it will be a thousand milliseconds one
second divided by FPS this will give us
the amount of milliseconds needed to
achieve this specific FPS
we will manage this Frame handling logic
down here inside render method if timer
is more than interval do something
at the same time keep increasing timer
by the value of delta time over and over
so when timer accumulated enough Delta
time enough milliseconds that its value
is more than interval we will animate
the next frame we will also reset timer
back to zero so that it can count again
for the future frame update
I will take all this code and I put it
inside the if statement like this
we are using Delta time value on line
173 that value will be passed as an
argument to render method up here
and
inside animation Loop we are calculating
Delta time here
and we will pass it to render like this
okay so something is happening the
reason everything is blinking is that we
are deleting old paint all the time but
only redrawing our game when timer
reaches interval
cut this clear rectangle from here so
now we are not clear in old paint at all
and everything is animating at 20 frames
per second and everything is leaving
trails
and I will clear old paint only when we
are ready to redraw the next updated
game frame here so context clear
rectangle from chlorine at 0 0
two distort with desktop height to clear
the entire game area one optimization
would be to draw our game on multiple
canvas elements and only clear the
portions of cannabis that actually
updated that way we wouldn't have to
redraw everything all the time for now
this will work fine you should be able
to see a slow down in-game animation
speed because we are setting FPS here to
20 to make it even more obvious maybe I
only want to animate 5 frames per second
30.
40.
50.
60. I'm setting fps to 60 frames per
second but we are not actually animating
our game at 60 FPS because every time I
reset timer back to zero there is some
leftover Delta time I am not accounting
for so even though I say 60 the actual
FPS is a bit lower I can go down and I
can account for that leftover Delta time
but maybe I want to keep this code base
lightweight maybe I don't want to make
JavaScript to do even more calculations
over and over so while keeping this in
mind I will know that I have to set fps
to a slightly higher value here to
actually get something around 60 FPS if
I set this to 70 I think we get smooth
enough movement and we are not making
JavaScript calculate leftover Delta time
which would slightly increase how
performance demanding our game is I just
thought of this now I'm not sure which
is a better solution I will leave my
code like this for now but I guess the
right solution here will be up to
everyone's personal preference feel free
to discuss this in the comments I will
consider your feedback in my future
projects now that we know how to control
animation speed of our game using Delta
time the game will run at a similar
speed on every machine even for those of
us who are using High refresh rate
screens
[Music]
I want to add eggs that can be pushed
around to include even more physics in
our game those eggs will be hatching
into creatures after a specific timer
has passed and player's job will be to
protect the creatures that hatch the
eggs can be pushed around by enemies but
they won't be destroyed the challenge
for the player is when they hatch
enemies will eat the hatchlings so
player's job in our game will be to
position the X to protect them or to
push enemies away from the path of the
newly hatched creatures The larva that
comes from each egg will always try to
crawl into safety and hide in the bushes
inside the mushroom Forest at the top
this will introduce a lot of player
choice and player options into our game
while using physics we implement it I
got an idea for this game a mechanic
while watching a nature documentary
where little baby turtles are hatching
on the beach and trying to get to the
Sea for safety in our game we control
the Blue bull its job is to protect the
hatchlings by pushing eggs larvas and
enemies around this game is all about
physics and positioning
I will have a custom class I call for
example egg Constructor will expect a
reference to the main game object as
usual to make sure EK class has access
to many important properties held on the
game object
X will be part of the game physics so I
need to make sure I Define separate X
and Y coordinates for Collision Circle
Center Point and for the Sprite sheet
let's start with Collision X property it
will be a random value between 0 and the
width of the game area
Collision y will be between 0 and game
height like this
Collision radius for example 40 pixels
this dot image will be
document.getelementbyid and the ID is
act
in index.html I actually have to create
that image element as always images can
be downloaded in the resources section
below
I hide it with CSS here I'm keeping the
same name and conventions across my
objects it's a good practice so Sprite
width will be 110 pixels and Sprite
height is 135 width and height will be
set to these same values
in our game every object has Collision X
and collision y properties that
represent the center point of collision
area Circle even player and obstacles
have the properties named like this so
that we can use reusable Collision
detection method to implement our
physics to everything same goes for
sprite X and Sprite y properties those
represent the top left corner position
from which the object's image will be
drawn Sprite X of egg image will be
Collision X plus half of the width of
the egg image to Center the image over
Collision Circle horizontally
Sprite y will be Collision y plus half
of image height
we might have to adjust this a bit later
because vertically we want the Collision
area to be at the base of the egg not in
the middle we'll get to that soon draw
method will expect context as an
argument as usual we call draw image and
this time we just need three arguments
the image we want to draw and X and Y
coordinates where to draw it
if we were scaling we would also include
optional width and height arguments like
this but I'm giving you all the images
in the same size we are drawing them in
game so it's actually not necessary
as with all game objects we are not only
drawing the image representing the
object we are also drawing Collision
Circle if debug mode is active since we
are keeping the same naming conventions
for properties all over our code base we
are making our life easier I can just
copy this entire code block and use it
here so we are drawing X image and if
debug mode is on we are drawing
Collision area
yes probably it's a good idea to put
this code in a reusable method since we
are using the same code to draw
Collision circles for everything I might
do that later for now I want to create a
method that will periodically add a new
egg into our game on the game class we
will have an array that will hold all
currently active egg objects
I will also have another property called
number of eggs
or Max X describes it even better
we will only be adding new x to the game
until the total is less or equal to Max
x value
[Music]
inside render method here we will handle
the logic to add X periodically we
already did it we did periodic event in
this code base where we use the Delta
time and triggered new game frame only
when a certain interval value was
reached we will actually do the same
thing here we will need some helper
variables for that egg timer will go
from 0 to X interval value then it will
add a new egg and it will reset so that
it can count again we are operating with
Delta time so milliseconds I want to add
a new X let's say every 500 milliseconds
down here I will check if egg timer is
more than egg interval
we add a new egg by calling this method
from line 220.
inside there I just take the X array I
call built-in array push method and I
will push one new instance of our custom
egg class in there as usual we know that
the egg glass expects the game as an
argument so
I pass it this keyword because we are
inside that game object here
so if egg timer is more than egg
interval we call add egg we will also
reset egg timer back to zero so that it
can count again towards the next egg
else we keep increasing egg timer by
Delta time which we are already passing
here to render method from before
I console log this.x to see if the
objects are being added
sorry this will just create an endlessly
growing array I need to create
additional condition here only add new X
as long as the length of X array is less
than Max X that's better
I inspect one of the egg objects
I need to make sure all the properties
have values if for example I have
undefined as Collision x coordinate my X
wouldn't be drawn on canvas because
JavaScript wouldn't know where to draw
them I see values on everything this
looks great
inside render method I would also like
to draw my X I just copy this line and I
adjust it for each element in X array we
will call it egg and we will call draw
method on it perfect now we are getting
some visuals which will make it even
easier for us to tweak the details and
polish it the first thing I notice is
that all the eggs are added almost
instantly even though I said I want one
egg every 500 milliseconds if I increase
egg interval to one second here I can
see that something is wrong with my code
I know the problem must be inside this
code block and
it's because egg timer is more than egg
interval and only then add a new egg we
need to use this comparison operator
here sorry about that typo you probably
noticed it already before now it works
we get one New Egg add it every one
second as long as we have less than 10x
I can also see that the egg images are
positioned outside the Collision circles
I change this plus to minus here and
also here
now that's better I want to adjust the X
Sprite sheet in relation to its
Collision circle plus 35 will move it up
minus 35 will move it down minus 30. I
want it to match the bottom of the image
as closely as possible but also I don't
want the Collision Circle to be too tall
because I want the player to be able to
walk behind the egg without pushing it
to have this illusion that our game area
is in 3D and that it has some depth even
though in reality it's just a flat
surface we will do more to enforce this
in a moment now I want to create a
margin to make sure the X appear certain
minimum distance from the edges of the
game area so that we can get the player
between the egg and the edge to push it
anywhere we want
I want the margin to be let's say
Collision radius times 2.
the initial X position of collision
Circle will be a random value starting
from left from that margin value we just
defined and game width minus that margin
down here I set X interval to 100
milliseconds and I want 50x
just to get a better idea where they can
possibly spawn in our game
we have that left margin I wanted but I
can see that the eggs are too far to the
right Edge so here I increase that right
margin like this
yeah I'm happy with this the eggs are
now always fully visible horizontally
with some extra space left and right
between the edges of the game area
vertically I will do something similar
but the random position needs to start
below the top margin area we defined
earlier I don't want any X in front of
this background artwork the way Master
random works I just pushed the range
from here to here I also need to narrow
the range down by reducing the span of
random values we get so game height
minus top margin
now X can appear from here to here
I will reduce the randomized value by
margin to give it some space at the
bottom like this
perfect if you are a beginner math at
random can be unintuitive it's actually
very simple it can just take some
practice so here I'm saying set
Collision y property to a random value
starting from Top margin here
because we're going from the top and the
range of random values is game height
minus that margin minus this other
margin so X can appear anywhere between
here and here vertically
I set interval to 500 milliseconds and
Max X to be for example 10 for now this
means we will get an egg appear every
half second until the total count is 10.
this is a physics game so we wanted the
player to be able to push the X around
to move them out of the way of incoming
enemies or to position them
strategically to give the larva that
will hatch from it the best chance of
survival in this game I choose that X
will be indestructible enemies will just
push the X out of the way if they
Collide but the larva that hatches will
be eaten if anime catches it so
positioning and pushing the X around is
very important let's give the X some
Physics
[Music]
I give each egg an update method inside
we will create a temporary helper array
called Collision object this will
contain all objects in our game that X
will interact with
we will check for collision between each
egg and this object so we will need
player here this dot game.player like
this and of course we need the solid
obstacles in here I want all these
elements to be on the same level in
Collision object array we have player
object here and we will spread obstacles
array into Collision object array using
spread operator like this
spread operator allows us to quickly
expand elements in an array into another
array
I will actually call this Collision
object with an s
I will call for each on it for each of
these objects so in this case for player
and all individual obstacles we have
here I want to use this check Collision
method we defined on line 225. if you
remember it takes object a and object b
as arguments and it returns an array
that gives us true or false for
Collision this stands between two
Collision Circle Center points some of
their radii and horizontal and vertical
distance between the two Center points I
copy this array
I paste it up here and again we will use
the structuring to quickly Define these
five variables using a single line of
code
I need a variable name here so I will
call the first one Collision true or
false whether the echo lights with
player or any obstacle we did this
before I want these to be lead variables
and they will be equal
to
this.game.check collision between this
egg because we are inside update method
on egg class and one of the objects in
collisions object array
so as the for each method runs we are
running check Collision method between
this egg and each element in this array
and we are getting five variables that
tell us more details about position and
collision of these two objects we are
comparing
if Collision is detected we will
actually use all these values to
calculate how far and in which direction
we want to push the egg
horizontal direction of the push will be
the ratio between DX the horizontal
distance between the two Center points
and the distance hypotenuse of that
imaginary right triangle because DX is a
side of that triangle and the distance
is hypotenuse the longest side we are
dividing a smaller value by a large
value because of that unit X will be
something between -1 and plus one DX can
be positive or negative
unit y vertical push direction will be
the ratio between d y and distance now
we will use this to move the egg we are
inside a code block that will only run
if egg is colliding with player or any
of the obstacles so when Collision
happens we take Collision X of the egg
and we push it one pixel outside of the
radius of the object it is colliding
with so Collision X of the object the
center point plus one extra pixel to
move the egg outside of collision area
so this is how far and the horizontal
direction of that move will be defined
by multiplying it by unit X which as we
said can be positive or negative
we also need to move the colliding egg
vertically collision center point Y of
the egg will be Collision y of the
object it's colliding with Plus radius
of egg Plus radius of the object plus
one extra pixel so that in the next Loop
Collision is false terms vertical
Direction defined by unit y notice that
here we are detecting collision and I am
a moving Collision X and collision y of
the egg based on the position of the
obstacle this is just my choice and
doing this will make the egg move and
all these elements will be solid in that
interaction when interaction happens egg
will move player and obstacles will
remain solid they will not be pushed by
the egg
down here we call draw method on each
egg we also want to call this new update
method we just wrote
Let's test it
we are pushing Collision circle of this
egg I need to make sure that Collision
area and Sprite stick together the
simplest way would be to take this code
that positions Sprite X and Sprite Y in
relation to Collision X and collision Y
and I will call it inside update method
I can remove the values here and now we
can push the X using player and they
will also Collide and slide around our
mushrooms and plants around the solid
obstacles the eggs don't interact with
each other this is just my choice I want
the X to overlap so that a skilled
player can push multiple eggs kind of
hurt them together and push all of them
at the same time this choice will also
keep our code simpler because we are
learning
[Music]
we are drawing everything on a single
canvas element so the draw order of our
game objects what is drawn behind and
what is up front will depend on the
order in which we call draw methods on
each object from inside render method
here right now I draw obstacles so
mushrooms and plants then I draw X so X
are drawn on top of obstacles as you can
see here and then we draw the player
player is drawn on top of everything
else if I take the X and draw them first
they will always be drawn behind the
obstacles and behind the player and here
we can see that it doesn't really make
visual sense I wanted to create an
illusion of depth fake 3D or maybe two
and a half D objects that are low should
be up front as we move up objects drawn
on that vertical Baseline should be
drawn behind for example this egg should
be drawn in front of this plant not
behind find it we can't really achieve
that if we draw all X then all obstacles
and then the player we need to adjust
our code a little bit I will have to put
all these objects into a single array
and I will sort that array based on
vertical coordinates let me show you
what I mean I create a new property on
the main game class I will call it game
object at first this will be an empty
array
in a side render method I will take a
game object and I will use spread
operator to expand the entire X array
inside
I will also expand the entire obstacles
array in here and I will add the player
now we are holding all the game objects
in a single array this array will be
recreated every time render method ticks
good optimization tip here would be to
only do this operation when vertical
coordinate of any element changes or
when we add or remove an egg I will
repurpose this code block and instead of
calling for each method on X array I
will call it on this new game object
array for each element in the array I
will assign it a temporary variable name
for example object for each object in
game objects array call their Associated
draw and update methods for this to work
it's important that all objects we add
into game objects array online 217 have
a draw and update methods defined on
their classes otherwise the code would
break because JavaScript wouldn't be
able to find that method
so we are calling draw and update on all
game objects on all X on all obstacles
and on the player that means I can now
delete these lines of code
typo here I spell the game objects with
an s now we draw the first obstacle and
then we get an error we call the draw on
the first obstacle and when we try to
call update on it we get a type error
that says object dot update is not a
function I go to my obstacle class and
you can see as I said we have draw
method here but there is no update
method we are asking JavaScript to call
a method that doesn't exist on this
object I will create an update method
here inside that method we could for
example animate Sprite sheets of these
plants and mushrooms every time the
player collides with them or something
maybe I will add some interactive
obstacles later for now we will leave
this method empty now it's working and
we are calling draw and update on all X
all obstacles and on the player
alternatively I could have also solved
the lack of update method on obstacles
by some kind of if else statement down
here there are always multiple ways to
do something feel free to discuss how
you would approach this different clay
maybe we will get some better Solutions
in the comments that I might use in
future classes I appreciate when you
give me feedback on my code and when you
suggest improvements
okay so now we are calling draw and
update as we cycle through game objects
which means X are drawn first obstacles
are on top of X and player is drawn last
on top of everything if I change the
order of these elements here the player
is drawn behind now then X and obstacles
are on top of everything so now we can
understand how the layering works it
depends on the order in which we call
draw method on each object to draw our
game objects in the order that makes
Visual sense I can now sort game objects
array based on each object's vertical
position I take game object array and I
call built-in array sort method this
method sorts the elements in an array
and it Returns the same array now sorted
by default if we call it without passing
it any arguments it will just convert
array elements into Strings and it will
sort them based on their Unicode values
we don't really want that so we will
pass it an argument this optional
argument we can pass to array sort
method is a compare function a custom
function that defines some logic it
defines some specific sort order we want
this special function will take two
arguments element a and element B all
elements in the array in our case in
game objects array will be represented
by this A and B and used in this logic
we Define here
I can do return like this and I want to
sort the elements in ascending order
based on the value of each object's
Collision y property so we are sorting
based on the vertical center point of
collision circle area alternatively we
could also sort by the bottom of sprite
image which would be sorted by the value
of sprite y plus Sprite height
sort method can be complicated to
understand if you are a beginner all you
have to understand here is that I'm
putting all my elements into game
objects array then I'm calling built-in
sort method on that array and I'm
organizing these elements based on their
vertical position
it doesn't work now because I'm creating
array I'm drawing and then I'm sorting I
need to sort the elements after I
created the array but before I draw them
so like this
perfect now this egg is drawn in front
of the plant but if I use the player to
push it up the X vertical position
becomes less than the vertical position
of the plant now the egg is drawn behind
the plant this is one simple way how you
can draw elements in a 2d game in a way
that makes more visual sense it is a
very powerful technique to add to your
coding toolkit do you have any questions
leave a comment
you don't have to do the following thing
I will do now I set X interval to 20
milliseconds and Max X will be 150 just
testing if there are any problems we
need to solve as I move through them the
physics seems very good it's all working
well having so many eggs for testing
also gives me a pretty good idea
where they might potentially spawn they
appear in the area we specified with
large top margin and smaller margin from
left bottom and right
we got X nice job coders
I set interval to thousand milliseconds
one egg every second and Max X will be
20. since we have this Collision formula
in place
If egg appears on top of obstacle or the
player it gets automatically pushed
outside its Collision radius
I remove this control lock on line 237
we have our game world we have
randomized solid obstacles we have Mouse
controlled player character that can
move in eight directions and we have X
that spawn in specific interval on top
of that everything collides and reacts
to everything we can make so many
different games with this let's add
enemies
[Music]
I create a custom class I call for
example anime as usual Constructor will
take a game as an argument and we
convert that reference to a class
property we do that to get an easy
access to all properties sitting on the
main game class from inside anime class
through this.game reference we need to
keep the same name and conventions here
so Collision radius 30 pixels Collision
X Center Point of collision Circle will
be the right edge of canvas
this.game.width a collision y will be a
random value between 0 and the game
height value coming from
here speed X horizontal speed will be a
random value between 0.5 and 3.5
you can download anime image in the
video description at first we will start
with a static single frame ID will be
told Source will be told.png
I hide it with CSS because we want to
draw it with the JavaScript on canvas
this dot image property will be get
element by ID and the ID we gave it was
told
Sprite with in this case 140 pixels and
Sprite height is 260. I will also create
width and height properties
and we will Define Sprite X and Sprite y
positions of the Sprite sheet image
which will be positioned in relation to
Collision Circle coordinates raw method
will take context as an argument
built-in draw image method and because
the image file I'm using is already the
same resolution as the size I want to
display it in the game I only need to
pass it three arguments the image I want
to draw and X and Y where to draw it
I will also copy Collision Circle visual
that will appear only when debug mode
property is set to True only when debug
mode is active
I just copy and paste it here since that
code is the same for all our objects
update method in there I want enemies to
move to the left in the minus Direction
on horizontal x-axis by speed x a value
we defined online
so we are moving enemies to the left if
the right edge of the Sprite sheet is
hidden behind the left edge of canvas we
can set its X position back to game
width so that it can walk left across
the screen again we will also randomize
its vertical y position to get the
enemies walking in different Lanes so I
will have enemies that walk from right
to left and then they reset and walk
again alternatively I could have also
created new anime objects over and over
and Destroy them discard them when they
move off screen the code would be simple
but reusing objects by resetting their
position rather than creating new ones
and discarding them later is a good
optimization technique always reuse your
objects and reset their positions if you
can rather than creating new ones using
the new keyword to create a new object
is more expensive than resetting
existing object
on the main game class I create a custom
method I call for example at enemy up
here we will have an array that will
hold all currently active anime objects
whenever add enemy runs it will push new
anime object into enemies array
upon line 174 I can see that anime class
Constructor expects game as an argument
so I pass it this keyword because here
we are inside this game class doing this
I'm just passing a reference that points
to a space in memory where game object
is stored I'm not creating a copy of
game object each time I create a new
enemy
init method will run just once to
initialize our game and set everything
up inside we are already creating
obstacles we will also create enemies in
here for Loop that will run let's say
three times and each time it runs it
will call add enemy method we just
defined icons to lock this dot enemies
and
as expected it contains three anime
objects I inspect one of them just to
make sure nothing is undefined which
could be a problem
all is good here I can delete the
console log it's a good idea to always
check your objects and arrays with
console logs as you build your project
step by step to catch potential bugs and
typos in time to draw and update enemies
I just have to expand enemies array into
game objects using the spread operator
we did that before
I see only Collision hitboxes I need to
give some values to Sprite X and Sprite
y so that the JavaScript knows where to
draw the images
position of the Sprite will be moving as
Collision circles move so I put that
code inside update method let's first
center it then we offset it Sprite X is
Collision x minus half of sprite width
like this
Sprite Y is Collision y minus half
height
I want the Collision circles to match
the shadow on the ground below our
floating enemies as closely as possible
we need to adjust image positions
vertically
minus 40.
minus 60
what about minus height
Plus 40.
I can enable and disable debug mode to
show and hide hitboxes by pressing
letter D we have enemies coming from
right to left and then reset in I want
them to reset all the way behind the
right Edge so we don't see them just pop
into existence so we reset them to
game.width plus width of anime
and on top of that another game with
times 0.5 to give each one A different
random delay
why is this here I delete that
just for testing let's increase the
speed
resetting them at a random offset behind
the right Edge works well
maybe that's a bit too fast
I need to restrict their vertical
positions let's say start from the top
margin
and from there a random range between 0
and game height minus top margin
I copy this value to be used as the
initial Collision X position inside the
Constructor and I take this new
Collision Y and I use it inside reset
check in update method
this will not work because up here on
line 176 I'm using this dot width but
it's not defined until later here on
Line 183
the order here matters
I just take these two lines and I put
them here
now we have enemies walking from right
to left in a correct Corridor and reset
in behind the right Edge this way we can
reuse the same enemies over and over
unless I decide we want to add some
other features like allowing player to
destroy enemies or something like that
we will see
again you don't have to do this part I'm
just testing our code
so I create 30 enemies
having so many enemies gives me a better
idea how they reset and I can spot any
potential issues faster
everything seems to be working well
this would be a very dangerous Forest
luckily for our hatchling creatures the
final game will not have swarms of
enemies like this unless you want to
create a periodic wave of enemies like
this as one of the gamer mechanics the
player has to prepare for and avoid we
can do so many things in terms of game
design here I'm just giving you the
tools and techniques and showing you
some of my ideas feel free to expand
this game with your creative ideas when
the course is finished let's go back to
three enemies
right now the enemies are just flying
through the forest without interacting
with anything first I want them to react
to solid obstacles and the player we
already have code that does that inside
update method on egg class I can
literally use the same code block and
put it inside update method on anime
class this will make enemies treat
obstacles and player as solid impossible
objects and they will slide around them
we are inside update method on enemy
class and we are passing anime as object
a and player and obstacles as object B
and here we are saying adjust position
of a based on position of B player and
obstacles will be solid and dominant in
this interaction and enemies will be
pushed around them this simple Collision
check-in will also create a very basic
artificial intelligence as you can see
enemies are walking from right to left
across the game area and they are
automatically slide in and avoiding
obstacles and the player
because they avoid the player in this
way we can also use the player to push
enemies around same as we can push the
ax around I adjust enemy speed
if I add X into Collision objects array
on anime class X will also become solid
impossible obstacles for the enemies and
enemies will have to walk around them
it might be a good thing depending how
you're designing your game but the way I
want my game to be I actually want to
remove the X from here
instead I go up to egg class and inside
update method I will add enemies to
Collision objects here
this will make the X object a passed to
check collisions method and enemies will
be solid impossible object B enemies
will push the X around if I do it this
way we implemented a lot of features so
I will leave the source code from this
stage in the resources section below you
can download it and compare it with your
files if you are coding along hope
you're having fun
[Music]
I go down here between egg and enemy
classes and I create a new class I call
for example larva I want eggs to have a
hidden timer and after a certain time
interval each egg will hatch into a
smaller larva that larva will try to
hide in the forest and our job as a
player is to protect it by pushing it
closer to the safety zone or by pushing
enemies away from it Constructor on
larva class will be a little bit
different because I want each larva to
appear at the same position as the egg
it hatched from so we will pass it a
reference to the main game object as
usual but also we pass it X and Y
coordinates now I convert all these
arguments into class properties I need
to name these X and Y coordinates
Collision X and collision y these
variables will be involved in Collision
detection so we need to name them the
same as we did other objects in our
physics game so that we can use our
reusable check Collision method on these
as well and involve these larva
hatchlings in the game physics Loop we
will also need Collision radius here
let's say 30 pixels for now you can
download larva image in the video
description
I added here with an ID of larva and
Source larva.png it's a Sprite sheet
with two frames
on this row we have a bold larva and
this one has some fluff behind the neck
just to give it some visual variety the
fluff makes more sense if you know what
these hatchlings turn into when they are
adults I bring the larva image into the
project using get element by ID like
this
width and height of a single frame now
Sprite width is 150 pixels Sprite height
is 150 pixels as well if you are a
beginner I strongly suggest you follow
my code exactly and use the same images
I'm using when the project is complete
it will be easier to make your own
custom changes changing the code as you
go while following this tutorial is not
a good idea unless you are an
experienced JavaScript developer making
your own changes before the project is
complete will make it harder to debug
we will also need Sprite X and Sprite Y
coordinates of the Sprite sheet image
each larvae will need to draw and update
methods as usual
draw method will take context as an
argument
inside we call built-in draw image and
we pass it image we want to draw and and
why coordinates where to draw it
I want each larva to be moving up
towards the safety of the mushroom
Forest this open area is full of enemies
and it's very dangerous speed y vertical
speed will be a random value between 1
and 2 for example
we defined Sprite X and Sprite y
properties that determine where the
Sprite sheet will be drawn but because
they will have to move every time larva
moves I need to be updating them over
and over from inside update method
Sprite X will be Collision x minus half
the width
Sprite y will be Collision y minus half
the height
I hide this image with CSS we give it an
ID of larva
[Music]
so we have a class we can use as a
blueprint to create a larva every time
an egg hatches let's write egg hatching
logic we will need two helper variables
hatch timer will go from zero to hatch
interval it will count milliseconds so
let's say I want the egg to hatch after
5 000 milliseconds after 5 Seconds
Insight update method we handle
collisions in this area and down here we
will handle hatching
if hatch timer we just defined is more
than hatch interval we do something
else we keep increasing hatch timer by
Delta time counting and accumulating
milliseconds Delta time will be passed
to update method up here on line 159.
this update method will receive it here
inside render
we calculated Delta time value before
inside animation Loop Delta time
contains the number of milliseconds that
happened between this animation frame
and the previous animation frame so
hatch timer is accumulating this Delta
time milliseconds between frames if
hatch timer is more than hatch interval
we will delete the egg and we will
replace it with a larva hmm
up here I create a property called
marked for deletion
down here we set marked for deletion to
true
I can be checking and removing the smart
for deletion objects for every animation
frame but it might be a little bit more
efficient to only restructure our arrays
when something gets actually marked so
here we will call a custom method I will
call for example remove game objects
down here on the main game class I will
Define that method
so far we are only marking X for
deletion so whenever this method runs I
will take the entire X array and I will
call built-in array filter method on it
array filter method will just create a
copy of this array but that new filtered
array will only contain elements that
pass the check provided in the Callback
function the check in this case will be
I only want X array to contain elements
that have marked for deletion property
set to false if anything has marked for
deletion set to true it will be filtered
out of the X array
this is so-called es6 fat Arrow function
syntax I'm saying take elements in X
array one by one assign each one a
temporary variable name object and on
each of these egg objects check if they
are marked for deletion property is
false exclamation mark means false if
marked for deletion on this egg is true
that egg will be filtered out of this
new array and this new filtered array is
assigned to the original X array and it
overrides it
hmm am I over explaining again
let's consolock this.game.x to see if x
are being removed and added
yes this is working perfect
when we are in debug mode I want the
hatch timer to be visible as a number
floating above each egg inside the draw
method here I call built-in fill text
method this method needs at least three
arguments text we want to draw and X and
Y coordinates where to draw it
I need to change font size rather than
changing font size every time draw
method runs on each egg I will set it up
here on line 10 on the first page load
this is a powerful optimization
technique font is a part of kind of a
state and frequent changes to Canvas
State can affect performance define
canvas properties such as fill style
line width stroke style and font in a
code block that runs as little as
possible ideally don't do this in a
method that runs 60 times per second on
multiple objects at the same time
although in some cases it might be
unavoidable all I'm saying here if you
can set canvas properties on the first
page load like this all this code will
run only once I set canvas font to 40
pixels helvetica I could have also
defined canvas font here in this draw
method but as I said that line of code
would run 60 times per second on each
active egg that's a lot of operations
that can be easily avoided by doing what
I just said hatch timer is this
ridiculous number with so many digits
after the decimal point let's clean this
up I create a helper variable called
display timer in here we will format
that number a bit before we draw it I
can for example take hatch timer and
call built-in to fixed method JavaScript
to fixed method converts a number to a
string and it rounds the string to a
specified number of decimals I actually
want 0 decimals I just want to see the
milliseconds
I used a display timer variable here to
actually draw it
I can adjust vertical position of the
text Maybe by Collision radius like this
up here I will set text align to Center
this will align the timers and X
horizontally
nice I want to push the timers even
further up above the eggs
maybe even more
let's go with 2.5
instead of milliseconds I just want to
see the seconds so I close hatch timer
in Brackets and multiply it times 0.001
now this is more readable we can see
number of seconds above each egg
let's make each egg hatch after three
seconds nice when the egg hatches it
gets removed by the filter method
on the main game class I create a
property called hatchlings and at first
I set it to an empty array whenever an
egg hatches we will push new larva into
this array up here on line 190 I can see
that larva expects game and X and Y
coordinates so when an egg hatches I
take this to the game.hatchlings array
and I push new larva inside
I pass it this Dot Game and I pass it X
and Y coordinates of this egg that it
hatched from
I removed this console log
inside render method I use spread
operator to expand hatch links into game
objects array so that they can be sorted
drawn and updated perfect we are making
progress
now that we can see what our hatchlings
look like we can go up to larva class
and clean this up
first we will check if the larva moved
to safety
they are safe as soon as they reach this
mushroom and bushes area where they can
hide so if Collision Y is less than this
dot game.top margin if larva moved past
this point we can set marked for
deletion on it to true we will delete
that larva because we don't want to draw
it anymore and we will call remove game
objects
online 350 inside remove game objects
method I do the same thing we did for x
filter the hatchlings array and if any
larva object in this array has marked
for deletion properties set the true
filter it out
just to check I will console log game
objects every time we remove a neck or a
larva
I get an error and it's because this
needs to be
this.game.removegame objects because
that method sits on our main game class
I want to draw Collision circles on
hatchlings I copy this code block from
enemy class
and I just paste it here
because our classes have the same name
and conventions on their properties it's
easy to reuse code like this
right now we are drawing the entire
Sprite sheet for each larva I want to
crop out just a single frame from coding
at 0 0 2 this.spruit and this dot Sprite
height
and we want to draw that cropped out
image at position Sprite X Sprite Y and
we need to give it width and height like
this nine arguments
I want to position a larva Sprite sheet
image in relation to its Collision
Circle
I try minus 50.
yes that will work I want the Collision
Circle to align with the bottom of its
body I think that will make the most
visual sense when interacting with game
environments and characters
I remove this console log on line 362.
[Music]
larva Sprite sheet has two frames but we
are drawing just the top one let's
randomize that frame y will be a random
value between 0 and 2 and since there is
no row 1.5 for example we need integers
whole numbers without decimal points
so I wrap this in mastered floor
this line of code will give us either 0
or 1 because my other floor will round
the value down to the nearest lower
integer
frame X will be always zero until later
in the class where I give you Advanced
Sprite sheet for animation
we will use frame x times Sprite width
here as Source X argument passed to draw
image method and we also need to Define
source y Source X and Source Y
coordinates combined will determine
which area of the Sprite sheet we are
cropping from
Source y will be frame y times Sprite
height
nice since frame Y is randomized to be
either 0 or 1 some hatch links use
Sprite image from row 0 and some use the
other one from row 1.
collision between hatch links and game
objects will be handled here
I go up here inside update method on egg
class and I copy this code block we will
make some changes to it but most of it
will be the same so we might as well
copy it so we don't have to write all of
that again
I paste it down here inside update
method on larva class
I will remove enemies from Collision
objects because enemies will have a
different type of interaction so larva
will automatically avoid player and
obstacles and we can also use the player
to push larva around
like this which will be an important
game mechanic
collision with enemies will be handled
down here
I take enemies array and I call for each
on it
for each anime object I will call them
anime for example for each one of them
call this callback function
basically I want to say if this larva
and this anime we are currently cycling
over with this for each method collide
one way to easily check if two game
objects Collide is to use our custom
check Collision method again I want to
check collision between this larva we
are inside larva class and each
individual enemy as this for each method
runs we know that our custom check
Collision method returns an array of
values it gives us Collision distance
sum of radii DX and Dy here I only want
the first argument Collision which will
be true or false depending on whether or
not this larva and this anime Collide
check Collision returns an array and I
want Collision status true or false I
want the first element in the array so
index 0 like this
so here we are using destructuring to
extract all five individual variables
from check Collision method here I am
directly accessing just the first value
with index 0 because I don't need the
other ones
the reason I don't need these other
values when larva and enemy Collide is
because there will be no pushing around
and no physics The larva will just get
eaten so I set marked for deletion on
this larva object to true
I will also call remove game objects to
filter that larva out of the hatchlinks
array I will also keep track of how many
hatchlings we lost in this custom
variable this.game that lost touch links
will be increased by one
and here where we check if larva moved
the safety of the mushroom Forest we
increase score by one so if we protect
larva by positioning X pushing enemies
away or by pushing larva towards the
forest if larva successfully hides in
the bushes we get one score point if
larva gets eaten lost touch links
variable will increase by 1. down here
on our main game class we created these
properties score will be initially set
to zero and lost hatchlings also
initially set to zero
[Music]
I can use console logs or something like
that to check if the code we just wrote
works but we need that text displayed to
the player anyway so down here we will
draw game status text
again we will use built-in canvas fill
text method which expects the text we
want to draw and X and Y coordinates
where to draw it I want to draw the word
score at coordinates 25 horizontally and
50 vertically
problem we have right now is that I want
this text to be left aligned and if you
remember the text above X the timer is
Center aligned I will have to isolate
this fill text call by wrapping it
between save and restore built-in canvas
methods then I can set text align to
left and I call Restore
save and restore methods work together
and we use them when we want to apply
specific settings only to a certain draw
call on canvas without affecting the
rest of our project I save canvas State
I set text align to left which will
affect only this fill text call where we
draw score and then restore method will
reset all canvas settings to what they
were when save was called in this case
it will only revert text the line back
from left to Center I hope that makes
sense this is a very useful technique
especially if you want to scale and
rotate your canvas drawings I do that in
some other classes for example in my
creative code in fractal class if you
want to know more about it now score is
left aligned and timers above X are
Center aligned perfect
I adjusted the text to draw I want to
say score colon space in quotes plus
this dodge core variable to make it
Dynamic now as hatchlinks move to safety
and height in the forest we can see our
score increases in debug mode I also
want to be able to see lost touch links
so if this.game.deback is true I copy
this line of code text will say lost
plus this dot lost touch links variable
actually we are inside game class here
so I need to say just this dot debug yes
I change vertical coordinate here and
now while in debug mode we are also
keeping track of how many hatch links
were eaten how many hatchlings collided
with enemies
[Music]
sometimes the larva hatches quickly and
is eaten too fast or sometimes larva
disappears very close to the top Edge
while enemy is nearby so it might not be
100 clear if it managed to get to the
safety or if it was eaten
I would like to add an additional visual
effect that will help us to make our
game clear and easy to read I want to
add two types of particle effects when
the larva hides in the bushes it will
interrupt a swarm of fireflies that were
sitting on the branches and they will
fly up in the air when player sees those
fireflies they know that larva is safe
if larva gets eaten I will try to come
up with a different very distinct
particle motion so if there are many
game objects in the same area we can
still tell what's going on by seeing
what type of particles are flying from
there
I will also use this opportunity to talk
about subclassing in JavaScript we will
have a parent particle class that will
contain all properties and methods
shared between all particle types this
is a so-called parent class also called
a superclass
Firefly extends this particle class this
is a child class also called a subclass
we will also have a class I call spark
that extends particle class like this we
have one parent class and two child
classes child classes will automatically
inherit properties and methods from the
parent class which will save us some
called repetition let's write the code
and talk about it a bit more as we go
along
the parent particle class Constructor
will expect game X and Y position
because fireflies and Sparks will always
fly out from the position where the
larva disappeared and let's add one more
for example color here maybe I want one
particle type to be gold and another one
blue depending on where in our code base
was that particle created I will show
you what I mean
I convert all these arguments into class
properties as usual I'm saying take
color that was passed as an argument
here and save it as color property on
this instance of particle class you know
how this works by now radius will be a
random value between 5 and 15 but I wrap
it in Master Floor to only allow
integers so no decimal points if we are
creating many particles you will notice
a big difference in performance when we
are using randomized values like this
compared to the setting the initial
radius to a fixed value of let's say 10
pixels for all particles randomizing
object values when creating many object
is very performance expensive you can
improve your game's performance by
trying to avoid Master random as much as
possible if you know you will be
creating many copies of that particular
object I know we will be creating many
particles we only have one player object
so there it doesn't really matter it
gets created once but over the course of
our game we will probably create
thousands of particles
one way to avoid this would be a
technique called object pooling you
create a pool of particle objects and
only draw them and use them when needed
when it comes to Performance that would
be much better than constantly creating
new ones and deleting them
speed X will be a random value between
-3 and plus 3. this means some particles
will move to the right in the positive
direction on the horizontal x-axis some
particles will move to the left if their
speed X is a negative value for vertical
speed it will be a random value between
0.5 and 2.5 pixels per animation frame
I want to use a little bit of
trigonometry to make the particles
rotate float and swirl around so we will
need an angle value initially I set it
to zero VA velocity of angle will
determine how fast is that angle value
increasing I will show you exactly how
to use this in a minute don't worry the
a will be a random value between these
two very small numbers
we will delete particles that moved off
screen initially I set their marked for
deletion to false
draw method will be on the parent
particle class as well so it will be
shared for all fireflies and all Sparks
I want to make sure that changes to kind
of a state we make here remain isolated
to this particular particle so I wrap
the drawing code between save and
restore built-in canvas methods
we set fill style to this dot color from
line 303
I call begin path to start a new shape
built-in Arc method will take horizontal
Center Point vertical Center Point
radius
start angle and end angle I want you to
draw a full circle so from 0 to math.pi
times two method pi times 2 is a value
in radians and it converts to 360
degrees it's a full circle we have to
use values in radians here when passing
them to Arc method then I call fill to
fill the path with color and I will also
stroke it because in our game everything
has this Vector art style with block
outlines I want the particles to match
it
glass Firefly will contain only update
method same for spark later when we call
draw method on Firefly class since this
class extends particle JavaScript will
automatically look for draw method and
for Constructor on the parent particle
class doing this will save us code
repetition I don't have to Define
Constructor and draw method twice if
it's shared for fireflies and for Sparks
we can only Define it once on the parent
class and the JavaScript will find it it
will be inherited fireflies will have
unique motion I'm thinking floating up
and swaying left and right which is very
easy to implement first we will be
increasing angle by VA angle velocity
for each animation frame then we will
increase Collision X by speed X since
speed X can be positive or negative they
can start going left or right randomly
Collision y will be minus equals speed y
because I want them to float up in the
negative Direction on the vertical
y-axis if a firefly moves all the way up
and it's hidden above the top edge of
game area so if it's Collision y center
point is less than 0 minus its radius we
set its marked for deletion to true and
we will call remove game objects
on the main game class I create a
property called particles it will be an
array and it will hold all currently
active particle objects
I expand particles into game objects so
that they can be sorted drawn and
updated
inside remove game objects I add one
more line of code to filter out particle
objects with marked for deletion
properties set to True like this
let's try to create some particles I
will create them up here on larva class
in this code block that runs when larva
hides in the forest we get a score point
and I want a swarm of fireflies to fly
out of the bushes
I take this.game.particles array and I
push one new Firefly inside
I remember that particle class
Constructor expects four arguments a
reference to the main game object as
usual so I just pass it this Dot Game
along from larva Constructor
initial start in X and Y of this
particle will be the last X and Y
position of the larva we just deleted
and color will be red for example just
to test it
nice we have red particles with white
outlines if I want more than one I just
create a for Loop let's say I want three
fireflies each time
foreign
color to Yellow
let's see what that looks like
nice particles need black stroke I can
set it inside the draw method on each
particle but in this project I'm not
using a stroke on many other things I
can just set a stroke to Black globally
here on line 9. This will be more
performance efficient it will also give
black Strokes for Collision circles
while we are in debug mode but I don't
really think it's a problem it might
look even better like this
[Music]
fireflies have a very basic left and
right upwards motion we are not using
that angle we are increasing endlessly
on line 327. easy way to make something
cycle back and forth is to pass ever
increase in angle value to master sign
or method cosine method
when your code is like this VA by how
much angle increases for each animation
frame will determine the speed of
swaying and this dot speed X will
determine the curve the radius how far
left and right the motion goes
perfect whenever larva successfully
hides in the forest we get a score point
and we get confirmation by seeing this
Firefly effect
I want Sparks to look different so that
in case that larva and Anime are
obscured behind obstacles or something
you can still see that the larva was
eaten based on the particle effect that
happens there
in here I will Define a different update
method with different code inside so
Firefly and Spark are both child classes
of the parent particle class they both
inherit code in particle class
Constructor and they both share its draw
method but each one will have a unique
update method where we handle motion
I will increase angle by angle velocity
VA again but I will slow it down so
times 0.5
horizontal Position will be minus equals
Mass DOT cosine we pass it this ever
increase in angle value to map it along
a cosine curve and we Define the radius
of that curve using speed X
Collision y will be minus equals method
sine and I pass it the same angle value
and radius of the curve is speed y value
we go back up to larva class and here if
larva collides with an enemy we delete
it and I want to create a swirl of
particles I will just copy this code
block we used to create three fireflies
and I copy it here in this case we want
to create three Sparks and color will be
blue
how do I do this now I need to push the
larva in front of anime to see what
happens when it gets eaten
nice we get blue Sparks and some kind of
circular motion just for testing
purposes I will create Sparks even when
larva hides in safety so that the
animation happens automatically more
often without me having to chase them
around
I need to see it so that I can adjust
the movement
what can we do with this I love
particles you can do so many different
movement patterns so easily for example
let's make them shrink if you try to
draw a circle using Arc method that has
radius less than zero you will get an
error so we have to be very careful here
I say if radius is more than 0.1 keep
reducing radius by a small value that
value needs to be less than 0.1 to make
sure we can't get below zero also if you
remember we are only removing old
particles if they move past the top edge
of canvas and these swirling particles
never do so I need another condition
here if radius is less than 0.2 just to
be safe set it's marked for deletion the
true and call remove game objects method
nice this looks interesting I want them
to kind of explode to both sides I
haven't mentioned it before because it's
not necessary to fully understand
trigonometry for this course sine and
cosine work together to map a circular
path if we give them the same values
look what happens if I swap sine and
cosine
all you have to understand about sine
and cosine for animation purposes is
that if you pass them ever increase in
angle value and when you attach these
values to vertical and horizontal
positions of your object you will get a
circle movement the best way to get some
clarity is to play with the values try
to break it adjust the code and see what
happens don't worry about fully
understanding trigonometry today it can
be complicated for beginners and it
takes a while to master
I'm drawing 30 particles here to give me
a better idea about the motion that
happens and if we get any edge cases
appear that needs to be accounted for
you don't have to do this I recommend
using only three particles each time for
performance reasons you can see the
Sparks are kind of swirly explosions I
like it the motion is very different
from fireflies I give them yellow color
here and I will go back to using
fireflies
let's see what that looks like so we
know how to extend JavaScript class to
avoid code repetition we created a
parent particle class and two child
classes Firefly that indicates to the
player that larva managed to hide in the
forest by disturbing a swarm of glowing
bugs that float away upwards and when
larva is eaten by an enemy it will turn
into a swirl of magical Sparks that
slowly shrink and disappear
I will go back to three fireflies here
and down here let's create three Sparks
or maybe five because they shrink so
fast and often they are obscured by
obstacles and other game objects we want
to make sure they get noticed when they
appear
I would also like to allow the player to
move the eggs to the forest to get score
Point immediately I want X to instantly
hatch when we push them high enough into
the safe area that egg will
automatically turn into larva and into
fireflies instantly and we will get a
score point I can do that up here on
line 179 where we check if Hutch timer
is more than hatch interval to turn egg
into a larva I want this code block to
also run if the egg was pushed to safety
zone if vertical position Collision Y is
less than this dot game.top margin
to test it maybe I should increase Hajj
interval otherwise these eggs hatch too
fast
I see an egg here no here and I push it
leave me alone okay now here we go it
hatched instantly while hatch timer was
only 7 seconds I try again with this egg
and yes this works and we are also
getting score points for that perfect
[Music]
I prepared many different enemies for
you you know how we have a single image
file with multiple obstacle types I also
prepared many different toad skins for
you that will play the role of enemies
in our game I had a lot of fun making
different variations and imagining what
types of special abilities and special
moves they could have
let's say for performance reasons we
want to use just a set of static images
for enemies we will also animate this
later if that's what you want in the
final version of the game everything
will be animated all the project images
can be downloaded from the resources
section below as usual I'm giving you
all this premium game art for free this
course is designed to give you the
maximum value possible feel free to use
these art assets for your own projects
if you want so I bring this Sprite sheet
with four frames 4 enemy types into the
project ID is told and source is
toads.png I hide it with CSS as usual
in script.js inside enemy class
Constructor we create two helper
variables that will help us navigate
around the Sprite sheet and crop out one
random frame for each enemy object frame
X will navigate around the Sprite sheet
horizontally and it will be initially
set to zero frame y will navigate
vertically and it will also start at
zero I will need the longest version of
draw image method to Define what image I
want to draw Source X Source y Source
width and Source height to specify which
rectangular area I want to crop out from
the source image and destination X
destination y destination width and
destination height to Define where we
put that cropped out piece of image on
destination canvas 9 arguments in Total
Image to draw cropping area and where to
put that cropped image let's start by
cropping just the top left frame so we
crop from coordinates 0 0 to code
coordinates Sprite with Sprite height
this Sprite sheet has only one column so
frame X will stay at zero I want to crop
out one vertical frame at random so
Source y of the cropping area will be
Sprite height pushing the start of the
cropping area here giving us this Frame
to actually see it I need to use the new
image with an ID of toads
so to be clear 0 times Sprite height
will give us this Frame 2 times Sprite
height will crop out this Frame the
value we pass is Source y to draw image
method will determine where do we start
cropping from vertically
instead of this hard-coded value we can
use frame y now when I give frame y a
different value it gives us different
enemy types
I want each anime object to be randomly
assigned to one of these images when
it's created so we have four rows math
at random times four and if I wrap it in
method floor frame y will be either 0 or
1 or 2 or 3. I will also replace Source
x with a dis.frame x times Sprite width
this will become relevant a bit later
when I give you the next Sprite sheet
for now let's leave frame X at zero it
would also be nice to randomly reassign
the image every time enemy moves off
screen and resets so we make use of all
available images I just randomized frame
y here like this to achieve that
to quickly test this I increase enemy
speed to a random value between 5 and 8
pixels per animation frame
enemies are resetting and images are
randomly changing every time they reset
perfect
let's go back to a lower speed
I set max X to 5. since we are using
static images for enemies at this stage
drawing them is very cheap in terms of
performance maybe I could increase the
number of enemies to 5 as well this is
starting to look really good
[Music]
I want to display a winning and losing
message on the main game class I create
a property I call for example winning
score for testing purposes I set it to
5. we will draw winning and losing
message down here
if score is more or equal to winning
score hmm
I will wrap it in save and restore to
restrict some drawing settings we will
use now only to that win or lose message
I want to draw a semi-transparent layer
to indicate the game is over and also to
make the message more contrasting
against the background so I set fill
style to block zero zero zero and 0.5
opacity then we will draw that black
semi-transparent rectangle over the
entire canvas from coordinate 0 0 to the
width and height of the game area
let's run this code to test it when we
reach score 3 we should get that
semi-transparent layer yes after that
rectangle is drawn I will change fill
style to White to make sure the text is
contrasting against the dark background
I set text align to Center
we will have a main message in large
letters and a secondary message in
smaller font I will just Define them
like this as lead variables and the
values these messages get will depend on
how well we played in any case this
message will only display after score is
more or equal to winning score but let's
say if we played well and we lost only 5
or less hatchlings we will get a winning
message
if we lost more than 5 we will get a
losing message the goal of the game is
pushing X hatchlings and enemies around
to make sure we protect as many as
possible so if we play well message 1
will say hmm let's play with words a bit
you can write anything you want as a
winning and losing message here so if we
win the main message in large letters
across the screen will say Bullseye and
some exclamation marks the secondary
smaller message will say you bullied the
bullies
if we lose the main message will say
bollocks
[Music]
secondary smaller message will say you
lost plus we will display Dynamic
variable value to show how many
hatchlings got eaten
plus hatchlings comma don't be a
pushover this is a physics game about
pushing things around we need to learn
to push better I'm using a good old
string concatenation to construct this
Dynamic message even better would be to
use template literals here if you are
familiar with modern JavaScript syntax
now we actually want to draw these
messages the large message one will be
for example 130 pixels helvetica
fill text method will take the text we
want to draw message one and X and Y
coordinates will be the middle of canvas
horizontally and vertically like this
the second message will be smaller 40
pixels helvetica
fill text will draw message 2 in the
middle of canvas as well
one more full text call that will say
final score space plus we will display
the final score value there plus full
stop to end the sentence and another
sentence will say press R to butt heads
again I want to show you how to
implement a very simple restart
functionality whenever we press letter r
on the keyboard I will also draw it in
the middle of canvas vertically and
horizontally now I have to space those
messages out so they are not drawn on
top of each other I adjust the vertical
position of message 1 by -20 pixels
moving it up in the negative Direction
on the vertical Y axis message 2 will be
plus 30 pushing it down
message 3 will be plus 80. let's see
what that looks like yes this spacing is
much better we have our winning message
when score is more than winning score we
set the game over to true
on the main game object I Define a game
over property and initially I set it to
false
the simplest thing we could do here is
to freeze animation when game over
happens I can do it for example down
here I say only serve the next animation
frame if game over is false when the
game over becomes true the game will
freeze
I said winning score to 1 just for
testing
and it will display winning or losing
message and it will freeze like this
I go down to line 519 and I delete this
bit I would like the game to keep
running but we will make new X stop
appearing and I will prevent enemies
from resetting so they just flow off
screen and stay there so whenever game
over happens the objects that are
already in the game area will just
finish the action they are doing but new
objects will no longer appear the game
will just finish playing out behind the
winning or losing message but new X will
no longer appear and enemies will stop
coming
player will still be interactive and we
can still move it around in the empty
game world
how do we implement this it's simple
first of all let's say winning or losing
message appears and we still have some
eggs hatching on larva class we will
make sure that we get score points only
if game over is false when game over
happens hatchlinks will still appear
from the remaining X but whatever
happens will no longer affect our score
points
on the enemy class I only want the
enemies to reset if game over is false
like this when the game over happens
enemies will finish their movement
across the game area but they will no
longer reset to the right so new enemies
will stop coming
down here we only want to add new X into
the game if game over is false when
winning or losing message appears the
existing X will still finish hatching
but new X will stop appearing
Let's test it
I have a winning message
I have some leftover eggs but these
hatchlings no longer increase our score
we have some remaining enemies but they
just slowly move off screen and don't
come back again player remains
interactive and we can still move it
around perfect I want to test the losing
message rather than intentionally
pushing hatchlings in front of enemies
to get eaten I will just manually set
lost touch links to 10 here on line 380.
yes we get our losing message this is
great I set lost touch links back to
zero
adding a custom font is easy you can
choose any font you want I will go to
Google fonts they have thousands of
fonts available there I want to use this
comic book inspired font called bangers
I click here to select the font and I
click up here which will generate some
code I can use to include this font in
my project I copy these three link tags
and I paste them up here in the head tag
in my index HTML file ideally before my
custom style sheet so the font is
available from there
then I copy the CSS rule I use it here
in the case of this project I can just
apply that font family to all elements
you might want to be more specific and
only apply it to the canvas element for
example now the font is available in our
project so up here on line 10. I said
canvas font to 40 pixels bangers this
will affect the text that the displays
score and timers above hatching eggs we
also want to set bangers here and here
if we want to use it for game over
messages
let's quickly win the game
yes this looks better doesn't it because
we use safe and restore here everything
I do in this area will remain restricted
to game over messages canvas Shadows are
performance expensive and some browsers
don't deal with it well but if I limit
them to this piece of text we will be
okay let's try it we need to Define
horizontal distance between shape and
the shadow it can be a positive or A
negative value depending on if you want
the shadow to be to the left or to the
right Shadow offset y can also be
positive or negative it will determine
vertical position of the shadow in
relation to its parent shape
Shadow color will be black we can also
Define Shadow blur if we want that one
is optional so I will leave it on
default 0 which means no blur keep in
mind that canvas shadows will only be
drawn if Shadow color is set to a
non-transparent value and if at least
one of the properties Shadow blur Shadow
offset X or Shadow offset Y is set to a
non-zero value Shadows give the text a
nice highlight and make it stand out
from the background a bit more
I set lost touch links to 10 again just
to see the losing message what it looks
like with new font and shadows nice this
looks great I set close touch links back
to zero
[Music]
we have this message here that says
press R to butt heads again which means
press R to restart the game what I'm
about to show you is the simplest way
you can Implement restart game
functionality on the player class I
create a custom method I call for
example restart inside I want to set
player properties to what they are when
a new game starts
let's have a quick look what we have
here I want the player to move to the
initial position
we will reset Collision X and collision
y
we will also make sure that Sprite image
moves along with the Collision Circle so
I will need these two lines of code so
play restart method will move player
Collision area and player Sprite sheet
back to its starting position
we go down here to the main game class
and here inside key down event listener
I say if key that was pressed is R call
restart method on game class
like this
I defined that method down here and in
here we will set all properties to their
initial State this will be different
from Project to project we just wrote
this code base so we are familiar with
it and we understand what needs to be
changed to restart the game back to its
initial State first we will call restart
method we just defined on the player
class Let's test it I move the player
and when I press letter r on the
keyboard player will move back to its
starting position so far so good we
could use a similar technique to give
the player an ability to rewind time for
example where we just set State and
position on X enemies and Hutch links to
what it was let's say five seconds ago
that might give us some interesting
gameplay anyway we wanted to restart the
game so up here in the Constructor I
check what needs to change I know I will
have to reset the contents of my arrays
I take obstacles X enemies hatchlings
and particles and I set all these back
to empty arrays like this
I test it
okay so when I press R now this happens
I need to run init method again to
recreate enemies and obstacles since we
deleted them
yes now when I restart obstacles get
regenerated at random positions and we
also generate new enemies I can see I
also need to reset the current Mouse
position
I take this.mouse and I set it to
these starting values actually so I can
just copy this
I also resetted this score back to zero
and also lost touch links
I also need to set game over to false to
make sure X keep appearing and enemies
keep resetting
Let's test it I play
I win the game I press R to reset I play
I win I reset
I play
I win seems to be working alright I set
winning score to 30.
okay I spent some time testing the
gameplay and there are a couple more
things we can adjust as you know we can
enable and disable debug mode by
pressing letter d
I'm here on our custom larva class I
would like our larva Hutch links to
interact with X inside update method on
larva class I use spread operator to
expand X into collisions objects array
doing this will make the eggs solid
impossible obstacles and hatchlings will
have to crawl around them this will make
the game a bit more difficult and player
will have to get more involved to get
the X out of the way to make sure the
hatchlings reach safe area as fast as
possible sometimes hatchlings can even
get stuck between multiple eggs and
obstacles and if we don't free them in
time they will get eaten by enemies
alternatively I can remove X from here I
go up to the egg class
and inside update method on egg class I
will expand hatch links into Collision
objects array this on the other hand
will make a game easier because not only
will the hatchlings be able to push the
X out of the way they will also
sometimes push the eggs in front of them
closer to the safety zone you can choose
what you want to do here yourself
depending on if you want your game to be
easy or more challenging at this point
you know this code base well enough so
if you want you can take some freedom
and adjust the gameplay however you want
I also want the Collision circles on
hatchlings to better match the Sprite
sheet
-40 here will work well I think to
better align the bottom of collision
circles with the bottom of bodies of the
hatchlings I want these Collision areas
to match the artwork as closely as
possible we are in debug mode now but
keep in mind that the game is meant to
be played with Collision circles hidden
when debug mode is Switched Off you can
use the same technique to better align
Collision circles on enemies with the
little shadow on the ground below each
enemy I will do that in a minute because
the next lesson we will focus on adding
new enemy types I will also give you all
the character sprite sheets and we will
add a lot of animations to this project
I had so much fun designing these
creatures and making them move I hope
you like it
I noticed one small Edge case bug when
we get game over message and leftover
enemies eat some leftover hatchlings
lost touch links variables still
increases we need to make sure that lost
touch links value stays the same after
game over message is displayed so I will
only run this code block if game over is
false this will also make the hatchlings
invulnerable under the game over screen
if you don't want that you can apply
this if statement only to one line of
code that increases those hatch links if
game over is false lost touch links plus
plus
in the extended version we will add more
features we will animate the player
hatchlings and enemies I will give you
static and animated Sprite sheets for
all these characters you will also get
the full source code but not only the
final source code but multiple stages as
we progress with the project from the
base game to the complete fully animated
version if you followed along and watch
this far you should be really proud of
yourself you can let me know by saying I
did it in the comment section below I'm
looking forward to see what projects you
come up with when you combine your
knowledge and your creativity I hope you
got maximum value today time is the most
valuable resource we have thank you for
spending your time with me I'll see you
soon